We are doing this show and the honor of
Derek,
the safari guide who was killed by
Cecil's cousin in Africa today will all
day my fucking facebook has been a mess
because of people angry at me thinking
that I really cared that this fucking
safari guide got killed.
But Abby Martin is here to straighten
everything out.
Did you.
Did you cry when Cecil?
No,
I didn't shed any tears.
no.
I cried when Jimmy Kimmel cried.
Yeah.
See,
these stories are just.
I just feel like they're manufactured
kind of outrage and feign outrage for
people to just feel better.
I mean,
yes,
of course you should love animals and
humans and have solidarity with all
living things,
but it just seemed really manufacturing.
Especially when I read interviews with
people who lived there and they were
like,
who the fuck is cecil the lion?
Like the way the hysteria in this
country made it seem like he was like
their national animal.
Like this was the lion that was like the
lion,
right?
This beloved creature.
And everyone was like,
why do Americans care so much about this
lion who no one had heard anything about
him at all until this guy killed them.
And then once we decided that there was
a name to.
So,
you know,
then it became this big thing where I
had justin wren,
who's a friend of mine who works in the
Congo,
he,
um,
he builds water wells for these people
in the Congo that don't have a fresh
water.
And he said the most sobering statistic
yesterday,
he said,
5,000
children between the age of up to the
age of five die every day in the Congo
because they drink dirty water.
$5,000
a day,
a day.
I can't even comprehend.
So insane.
It's impossible to wrap your head
around.
And you know,
black lives don't matter.
Lions matter.
Seriously.
I mean,
when you're,
that someone else wrote a really
poignant editorial like this African
woman.
And she was just like this,
you know,
there's so much death and destruction
basically because of just so many
things.
Globalization,
especially with the raping of the Congo,
the civil war there.
And she was like,
but lions matter more than black lives
and that's the absolute truth.
And I think when people can
anthropomorphize this creature and feel
some sort of connection to it,
you can do that about anything you can
do that about.
We do it for,
with our dogs.
But the truth is we're eating animals
every day.
Um,
you know,
it just seemed like picking and choosing
just because it's this majestic
creature.
Yeah.
It was also,
it gives people an opportunity to be
really angry and not think about the
real problems.
Like there was all these people in front
of Cecil's,
uh,
or this guy,
the dentist,
a dentist's office,
and they were saying they should have
his head on their wall.
People,
I would like to see his head on a wall
like you really want.
Do you want a person to be killed now
to.
Well,
you know what,
I actually hit me a little bit too close
to home because I saw the,
um,
this kind of wave of hysteria and like
vitriol against this guy and actual
lambasting him with the death threats
over and over again.
People going in Samaritan blood on his
office and stuff and I just
was really,
really horrified because I was like,
Holy Shit,
this,
this happened to me on a really micro
scale with the Chris Kyle stuff.
I was just like getting like incessantly
peddled with death threats and that's
awful.
It's wrong.
You can't do that to someone.
We're all human beings and you can't do
that.
Even if you hate someone or think that
they,
you know,
if you personally want someone to die,
like you can't just be like,
you should die because you hunted a
line,
you should die because you were a fuck
Chris Kyle shirt.
I just think that apply it across the
board and this kind of online bullying
and like driving people into a hole or
doxing them and exposing their personal
information because you disagree with
something that they did.
It's wrong.
Mia Farrow Docs,
the dentist,
Pharaoh,
she put the dentist to dress online.
Wow.
The last person that I would ever expect
to do that.
That's so interesting.
Wow.
Shit.
To fuck with you,
Ellen.
What do you want for it?
It's not a joke,
it's not a joke to get docs and to get
like peddled with death threats.
Well,
you,
uh,
you had the Chris Kyle t shirt the fuck
cruise.
Carl t shirt.
Was that,
what did it for?
Was it the being on the show that did
it?
So you did warn me.
I'm just in case people haven't heard
the last episode that I was on.
Um,
I talked about how Chris Kyle was a
sociopath.
I talked about how he lied in his book
about,
you know,
killing people.
I'm beating dogs or horses so bad that
his hand broke.
But the thing is he's lied about so many
things.
I just even tours proven that he lied
about that fight and stuff.
So we can't really trust what he said in
his book.
But I think it's just odd that someone
would lie about killing black people in
Hurricane Katrina.
Like why would you brag about that?
You think that you would brag about a
story about like saving a child,
but instead he talked about how he was
actually bragging about like
slaughtering people who release,
which is super fucking weird or stealing
things super fucking weird and I just
want to make it very clear that I have a
lot of respect for veterans and soldiers
who choose a defect.
They,
there's a lot of heroic people like Ben
Griffin,
special operations and in the UK who
basically went to Iraq and just refuse
to go back.
So there's a ton of amazing veterans and
soldiers who I think that should be
praised,
especially when we're looking at
something like the Iraq war,
which was a complete disaster,
countless dead,
callous,
maimed.
Now Isis is erupted.
So when we have these heroes that are
mythologized in our society and when we
have someone like Chris Kyle,
who's the pinnacle of what the hero
should be from that war and rewriting
the history of the Iraq war,
I think it's really dangerous.
So I just,
you know,
I,
I talked about how,
what I really felt about Chris Kyle and
um,
people got really upset.
My friend Leo who runs this clothing
company,
printed a shirt,
a one off shirt fuckers,
kyle,
and he was just like,
he want,
he wanted me to wear it.
I was like,
yeah,
fuck it,
let's,
let's take a photo.
And I posted on my instagram account,
my instagram account,
like doesn't have that many followers.
I was like,
I did not know the shitstorm that would
be in suing whatsoever.
So,
you know,
war the fuck Chris Collared Shirt,
tits out.
Um,
you know,
two weeks go by and I was like,
whatever.
Nothing happened.
I wake up to every,
like it almost started where I was like,
Oh shit,
this is gonna be a really good art
project because I was getting peddled
with like the craziest shit you've ever
heard.
Like rape,
like genital mutilation.
So detailed that I was like,
is this isis actually writing these
comments because it seems like these
people actually admire racists because
it's like the most grotesque disturbing
things about my vagina and what they
wanted isis to do to it that I was like,
holy fuck.
Like you guys must have like some sick
admiration for Isis.
Don't.
When you saw that,
do you report those people?
So it started.
I remember I was going to Baltimore and
I just was getting it so frequently that
I was like,
holy fuck.
So my instagram,
I kind of had to like make it private
immediately because someone had gone,
like people had gone through and said
we're going to put our raping shoes on
and find you all this shit,
you know?
So I,
I shut that down.
And then I went on facebook and saw
that,
you know,
every single art post that I had on my
art page,
every single public.
So I had to,
like,
I didn't want to shut it down because I
was like,
I don't want to defer to these threats,
but at the same time it was getting so
extreme that I couldn't handle it,
like the volume of,
of death and rape threats because at
first I was like category cataloging
them and I was like,
okay,
I'm taking screenshots of all these,
I'm going to make this giant like,
like art project.
And I was like,
Oh fuck this,
this is like,
not that,
this is actually getting way,
way too crazy.
Um,
and then I got doxed by this guy.
I'm this veteran who basically just
wrote me and he was like,
Hey,
I just posted your address and all the
veteran and sniper forums.
I was like,
there's sniper forms.
And he was like telling people you know
how to find you.
And then I found out that my mom got
doxed so my mom's personal information
got exposed.
And so luckily I was already moving in a
week,
but I was just like,
this is,
this is shit crazy.
So I tried to contact the cops for like
the,
I think there was like 10 really graphic
like I'm going to come to your house
this Saturday,
cut your clit off,
like let you bleed to death on the
floor.
Like just,
I mean things like that.
I was like,
and it was a person's public facebook
page.
You can see as like license plate in the
photo.
He had like a baby,
you know,
they're just like these people out there
who are just totally proud to be like
completely homicidal and rapey and
really sociopathic acting.
So I went to the cops and I was like,
look,
there's like five people who I know who
they are.
They've said that they're going to come
kill me or raped me or cut my clit off.
And I was like,
is there anything that you can,
you can do?
And they basically just took the report
and nothing ever happened.
We were supposed to go to the FBI.
Didn't do it was so funny.
I called the FBI and they're like,
yeah.
They're like,
oh,
online threats?
Yeah.
Just go to this website and file it.
Like,
there's probably so many online threats
going on every day.
Oh my God.
Especially with killing.
Yeah.
I mean,
the thing,
the thing that was just,
it just upset me so much because people
were.
People were comparing me to like Pamela
Geller.
They're like,
okay,
you can wear a fuckers kyle shirt and
like Pamela Geller can have the drama
Muhammad contest.
I'm like,
first of all,
Stop Dfi.
And Chris Kyle was like a prophet.
Like,
that's insane.
Um,
second of all,
we're not talking about a marginalized
portion of society,
which is like Arabs who are basically
like this,
this generation's like demonized
population.
I was like,
we're talking about Chris Kyle,
which is like the peak of the empire,
this,
you know,
homicidal soldier who's like glorified
and in war propaganda and shit.
So you can't really compare the two.
But I just think it's really important
to understand the real history of the
Iraq war and I think American sniper
really not only whitewashed it but just
doubled down on the myth and the
establishment chooses these war heroes
to perpetuate.
And Chris Kyle is not a hero.
I think that there are countless heroes
that we would be much more appropriate
to hail.
Well,
it's hard too,
when you look at a story like the
American sniper story,
it's hard to figure out what really
happened because there were definitely
some fabrications.
So it's hard to figure out,
okay.
Military people,
when they retire,
they do not get much money.
It's,
it's,
it's piss poor and it's,
it's quite an embarrassment.
It's an embarrassment as far as the way
they're treated medically.
Um,
the,
uh,
the UFC has worked really hard to
provide money for the intrepid institute
for,
um,
but for traumatic brain injuries,
which is a huge issue with soldiers
because the medical community has made
so many incredible advances that people
live that didn't live,
you know,
30,
40 years ago.
So now these,
these guys are living with some
significant brain injuries.
And while we were doing one of these
fundraisers,
it was,
it was hitting me.
I was like,
why the amount of billions and billions
of dollars that are spent on this war,
how the fuck could they not allocate a
similar amount to take care of the
soldiers?
Because the soldiers don't have a voice,
like nobody gives a fuck for them.
Nobody cares.
So when these guys retire,
there's not a lot of options.
And so I was trying to figure out,
okay,
why would a guy like Chris Kyle make up
all these stories?
He was talking about shooting car
jackers in Texas that turned out to not
be true.
He said he was shooting people and
Katrina that were looting.
There was all these stories that didn't
hold water and I was trying to think it
was do you that maybe this guy was
trying to fabricate a bunch of crazy
shit and put it in his book because it
would make the book more sensational and
sell.
And this would be a way that this guy
could provide for his family.
Oh,
you mean me?
Like,
yeah,
bringing it back to the human level,
I'm sure.
But I mean I keep going back to the
people who just is like,
yeah,
I feel for soldiers who come back with
traumatic brain injuries.
But I do honestly think,
especially,
uh,
you know,
dating a veteran who was in the initial
invasion of Iraq and stuff,
um,
there are people who the military
because they want to kill people.
A lot of people joined the military
because they have no options.
because they believed in the Iraq war
and the war on terror and a lot of
people just want to slaughter people.
And I think Chris Kyle was one of those
people,
unfortunately.
Do you think you become one of those
people once you get out there?
Exacerbated?
Yeah,
astronomically.
Yeah.
Once you shoot the first few people like
me and that was a part of the,
the movies that the first person he shot
was a kid,
you know,
first of all,
the movie wasn't good and I was really
confused by that.
You didn't think it was good?
No,
that was terrible.
I thought it was a terrible movie.
Wasn't well done.
It was like a clunky made for TV movie.
It felt like to me.
Did you see it?
No,
it's not gonna.
It's not a good movie.
In Arusha fear was talking about how bad
it was and I was,
I thought when Ari was saying that,
that he was just being hypercritical.
Ari hates a lot of things and I'm like,
oh my God,
maybe he's sorry,
but our watch,
I was like,
this is not a good movie.
It's just not a good movie.
And you know,
Bradley Cooper is a really good actor,
but it was wooden.
I felt like I felt like it was just,
it wasn't,
didn't have a life to.
It goes to Chris Kyland and felt like it
was just.
Oh Man.
Did he really say that?
Yeah,
that's what I was like,
oh,
he's going for it.
Going for all in golf,
a Hollywood superstar who wants to be
the guy.
I'm seeing the movie.
Yeah.
And aside from just the movie,
be mad.
I think it's just unfortunate to kind of
personalize this character so much when
you know,
ignoring basically people came out of
the movie,
sanding rockies are savages,
and it was all like justified because
they're looking through the eyes of
someone like Chris Kyle when really,
I mean,
look at Iraq today.
Millions of refugees,
I mean,
as I just said,
the culture is just completely destroyed
and it's like,
what about those people?
So it's important.
Yeah,
we can humanize Chris Kyle and of course
we can humanize every soldier that's
coming back because they were sold false
pretenses to go to war.
But um,
I just have to feel more for the,
for the people who are just the
occupants of the country and they just
were casualties of this mess
should I think we should feel for all
humans equally,
especially people that we don't know.
And the idea that they're not as
valuable because they live over there.
Yeah.
If there was something that happened
over here where there was a foreign
invasion that caused a million
casualties that from innocent civilians
would be up in arms and horrified.
And I don't know what the real numbers
are for the Iraq invasion because it's
hard to figure it out.
There's a bunch of different argued
numbers.
Let's say it's the low ball number,
which is more than a hundred thousand
innocent civilians.
That's horrific.
It's horrific to think that that's the
low ball number and the high ball
number,
somewhere around 2 million Sam Harris.
Come on right up to this big on the low
ball numbers.
Here's
the problem.
And I am,
I'm,
this is all I'm going to say about Santa
Ana because I know that you offered the
debate and I really appreciate that
night.
Um,
I really,
really appreciate you offering that
because I know that we've been going
back and forth on twitter and shit.
I've gone back and forth.
Oh,
like he,
he actually wrote or he,
you know,
just the firehose of bullshit saying
that all I was saying was like
hyperbolic sensational figures and
stuff.
And the problem that I have with Sam
Harris and debating him is that,
um,
I don't feel like I should or need to
debate in neuroscience about foreign
policy.
Like I don't.
I'm interested in what he has to say
about like neuroscience and interesting
things that are like what he studied,
but as far as someone arguing with me
about like the US foreign policy and
empire,
um,
who's a neuroscientist,
I don't see any reason that I would get
out of that.
Especially someone who talks about mass
casualties with zero empathy.
Um,
I don't necessarily think he's talking
about it with zero.
Empathy I think was like a stone cold
killer was trying to be objective about
the numbers and not interject emotions
with it.
Totally.
But don't you think that he would say,
why would I talk to someone who was a
reporter about foreign policy?
No.
Journalists I think are much more
credible than just like scientists who
are just jumping into mix new atheism
movement and just being like,
let's,
let's have a giant debate all about
Islam.
I don't,
I just don't get it.
I mean,
the,
the information information is available
to anybody in this day and age.
Right?
It's innovate in what he is.
Maybe he has a degree in neuroscience
and he is a neuroscientist,
but really he's an author and he
researches things and he talks about
things and agree with them or disagree
with them in the way he presents the
numbers and the way he's presenting
this,
this argument.
I think there's a lot of debate as far
as how many people died over there.
Yeah.
Well here's the number.
Here's the problem with hin is that this
is.
He's.
He's basically.
He nitpicked all my numbers saying that
they were huge,
but all he did was basically site
official casualty count numbers from the
Pentagon.
It's like,
do you think that that's the fucking
neck or number that's way worse going to
the lowest ball number of casualties and
saying this is cited.
Some other people as well,
and the high number that he was citing I
think was around 200,000.
Right?
It was that do.
I don't remember.
I'm not good at recalling numbers.
I just think it's.
I just think it's funny that that's what
he hammered in on his meat.
Basically blowing up the numbers when he
basically went to the.
The most extreme small calculations that
have been determined by military
personnel when,
when basically the General Dempsey said,
we don't do body counts.
That's what he said during the Iraq war.
We don't do body counts,
so yeah,
it is really hard to tell how many
people died,
but the international business times did
a study in 2006.
It said a million were dead at that
point.
So yeah,
it is hard.
I just am sending include,
but they include Shia and Sunni in
fighting as well.
Right.
Which is a lot of it was caused by the
Iraq war,
which really triggered a huge amount of
civil unrest because there was a power
going on between
the Sunni and the Shia,
which were was more under control when
Saddam Hussein was in control of our
rack.
That is calculated in that casualty
figure.
That's.
Well,
yeah,
and a direct result of like a directory
and that's what brings it really high.
It's really bad and I think that's one
of the things that he argues against
that you can't attribute that to the
United States military invasion because
it's sort of a side effect of the
military invasion,
the civil war that's going on there.
Even though all,
even though Cheney back in 2000 or 1996
said,
this is exactly what's gonna happen.
If we invaded Iraq,
pieces of Iraq are going to fly off
Saddam.
We can never out him at this point
because this is exactly what's gonna
happen.
So it's like,
yeah,
you can say that was just a
happenstance,
but the truth is everyone knew what was
gonna happen.
So you know.
Well,
I think that's what he's just saying,
that it's difficult to attribute that.
Number two,
what the United States is responsible
for because it's really civil war
or based on a complete destabilization
and destruction of an entire.
The entire pot
emulation and entire population that was
run by an evil dictator in his
homicidal,
sociopathic sons and yeah,
I mean it was all gross before that to
mean more people are dead now,
but it was gross.
Then it's gross.
Now the whole world is terrifying.
You know the,
the thing about Isis,
did you see that shit with a,
blew up some ancient structures a couple
of days ago.
They,
they blew up some,
uh,
ancient monuments.
Pull that up because this is fucking
terrifying.
They beheaded some guy who's the head of
antiquities in Syria,
uh,
apparently this beloved guy who just was
unwilling to bow to their demands,
they behead this guy and then they blew
up some ancient monuments.
Some are really well preserved ancient
structures that were,
you know,
archeological treasures.
They're blowing these fucking things out
of the Taliban.
Blew up all those like Buddhist.
Now look at this fucking unbelievable.
They released the first images showing
the destruction of the temple in
Balsamiq fuck off.
I said that right?
It's just insane how rich isis is.
Like they've just stolen so much
equipment and money.
It's just the whole isis thing is so
disturbing because it is like,
it's like a self fulfilling prophecy.
It's like everyone's wanted this,
this group of like crazy Islam as that
we can look at and be like,
look,
this is why we need this,
like never ending war and isis just be
co comes out of the shadows of like
destabilizing an entire region of the
earth.
Um,
and this is what happens.
It's like this is the manifestation of,
you know,
well,
this is what the tin foil hat people
have always been saying.
The United States engineer's the United
States will prop up a country,
prop up a military,
and then go in and invade them.
One,
we got to invade them.
They're dangerous.
They're dangerous because we made them
dangerous.
Mean this is the
conspiracy theory.
Because when you remember when Obama was
on tv saying that we had to invade
Syria.
Yes,
only two years ago he was ready to Bama
side and we were all like,
what the fuck?
And the United States.
Pretty much universally it was like,
fuck it,
we're not going into another place.
We're not gonna.
We're not gonna start another war that
we can't win.
And then the United States backed off.
They just let it go,
but then coincidentally,
the rise of Isis,
like right when that happened.
I mean,
fuck man.
If you wanted to make a conspiracy
theory,
there's no better one than the isis.
It's right in front of everybody's face.
It's adorable and how ridiculous it is.
Like,
and I'm not saying that it's a
conspiracy theory.
I believe that this is real,
but it's amazing how quick it filled the
void left by our hysteria to go into
Syria.
Like,
oh,
will you reduce our grass bombing and
are they using poisonous gas?
That was the thing,
right?
Poisonous gas as well.
There's rules how you're supposed to
kill people.
We'll also why his WMD,
that pretense that we should just go in
and invade a country.
It's like,
oh,
like the Iraq war.
It's so funny because people are like,
we didn't find WMD.
They light.
It's like if we did find WMD is would it
have been justified?
Then like just because Assad is kind of
glove,
is that justified to go and fucking
invade the country?
It's so weird.
There was a crazy hysteria.
They'll post nine slash 11.
That was just undeniable,
there's a blood lust than America that
couldn't be ignored and then they just
pointed it at something.
So in Iraq and we were over there before
anybody was like,
wait,
what the fuck?
Iraq.
Like it didn't make any sense like that
had nothing to do with it.
Meanwhile,
Saudi Arabia,
which is where all the fucking hijackers
came from,
we were like,
oil money.
We liked those guys.
No,
no,
no.
I racked,
Whoa,
that guy's an asshole.
Fuck his son's a piece of shit and
they've got oil.
Let's get over there,
let's go.
And then we were over there,
now we're in Syria with Isis and Obama
just issued this statement saying like,
we can now attack Assad forces while
battling isis if we need to.
So it's just another proxy war that's
gotten completely out of hand with
future.
Look at these people that were training
to these FSA people and like,
I mean they're beheading people and shit
too.
They were like acting like Isis.
I mean,
it's insane.
The fsn basically like training all
these Syrian.
I'm like revolutionaries,
you know,
all these people in these rebel groups.
And then they go over either abandoned
post after we spent a shitload of money
training them to fight isis or they join
isis.
It's a complete disaster.
Well,
it's hard to get Muslims to fight
against Muslims.
You know,
when their core values and their core
beliefs in religion are so much a part
of their life.
And then they have these people that are
telling them that you're supposed to
fight these people that have the same
core values that celebrate Ramadan,
that believe in hello,
they,
they have the same ideas that these
people.
I was like,
it's way easier to stick with them and
some guy direct some asshole directing
you mccain from mother fucker from a DC
America,
the Great Satan.
Those fucking people that have killed a
million people in Iraq or whatever the
number is.
Sam Harris,
you know,
it's,
it's amazing.
It's a,
it's an amazing quagmire that we're in.
Right?
It's so interesting though,
when you look at like every like civil
war that's happened in the last 10
years,
like Libya and then you know,
you have Ukraine going on Syria.
Mccain is just always there playing
poker.
The hands of the people on the flag in
the fucking world.
You're like,
why are I doing?
Who is paying you to be here?
My favorite time when he was,
they were voting on whether or not we
should go into Syria and he was playing
poker on his phone number.
Hey,
yeah.
You're just like kicking it on his
phone.
Imagine you're,
you're about to.
You're part of a military decision that
who knows how many fucking people it's
going to kill whether or not it's going
to trigger world war three,
whether it's going to trigger a new
nuclear war and he's playing poker on
his phone.
He doesn't give a fuck and get a nice
water running through his veins hanging
out,
just kicking it.
You know,
he,
uh,
is so adorable that he would do that,
that he wouldn't think that people would
know holding onto a sharpie playing
poker on his phone.
He's such a piece of shit.
He actually tweeted it like someone from
his campaign,
which is so hilarious,
like tweeted at me saying,
thank you Vladimir Putin.
I see the,
just like paying attention to what I'm
doing.
And He,
like basically called me,
I was just like a report that I did and
I was like,
thank you John Mccain,
you seen our motherfucker,
you just tweeted out a scathing report
about your war crimes to like all of
your stupid followers on twitter,
some idiot running your campaign,
like tweeted out this video that just
exposed the fuck out of him.
It was great.
That's hilarious.
You tweeted something and he wrote it.
I did a giant video just breaking down
what?
Like a scumbag he is.
And um,
and he tweeted it out.
Oh,
so you didn't even tweet.
He just tweeted your video.
Wow.
It was great.
Well that's called damage control.
And understand you've got to ridicule
the information as Vladimir Putin.
Like as if America continues his attacks
against me.
That's what he said.
I'm honored.
That's hilarious.
Vladimir running our t Vladimir,
running my show up.
Did you ever meet that dude?
You never met him.
Did it feel like drip like the fucking
Lord Kgb,
mother and Dad.
I'm done
so funny watching him.
Every time he does like a sit down,
he always just says the weirdest shit.
He just like on another level,
like Obama tried to crack a joke within.
They're sitting at some press conference
and it's him and Obama sitting there and
he just like looks at Obama and he was
like,
you're trying to make this funny right
now and it's not.
Or something like just like completely
or Obama's like stay there.
Nervously laughing.
He was just like,
stop doing this.
These serious.
You're like,
okay,
kill a lot more people personally than
I'm sure.
How many people you think that guys
killed Obama but not with his own hands
to kgb.
Anybody knows how crazy that shit is.
He doesn't.
How many?
How many has he personally killed?
Yeah,
definitely.
Apple couple.
Probably KGB.
CIA,
that's for sure.
Yeah.
I mean like at least George Bush's Dad.
Herbert Walker Bush was the head of the
CIA.
That was a real killer.
He was a real stone cold motherfucker.
That's a fucking guy.
He's winking with the wrong guy to.
I don't trust that dominant left eye.
What kind of creepy shit is at holding
the gun with the right hand?
Squeezing the trigger.
Like those.
I like the photo of the glasses.
It always shows those reflect on.
Well,
you remember when that guy,
who's the guy that got murdered in broad
daylight with his girlfriend,
that was a.
nobody remembers that.
What happens is he kill pooting.
People just forget your name and it just
water under the bridge.
Just vanish.
That's a fucking crazy country right
now.
Roy Jones Jr is going to be a citizen.
Apparently they,
this is what he said was just fucking
hilarious.
He goes,
uh,
the people of Russia love Roy Jones Jr.
I love it when people love me.
It's like the dude who went to North
Korea.
Um,
wait,
who was that?
Basketball player?
Basketball.
Well,
I just Roy Jones as a career over there.
He's boxed over there a few times and
they like his music.
He plays music over there and apparently
they enjoy that music.
Yeah.
So junior trying to get citizenship.
They're gonna.
Give him citizenship.
Good friend edward snowden.
You get to your visa,
you get a visa for you.
Um,
so yeah,
was probably sucking some kgb dick right
now.
Keep his visa going to shit.
They make that guy do just to stay
there.
I'm sure nothing dude,
they're probably just love that he's
there.
Don't you think?
Just a thorn in the side maybe,
but he can't go anywhere.
I mean it's not like he can.
He can't go anywhere.
No,
he probably has to like hide wally's.
Even in Russia,
just for fear of american agents.
Just takIng them out.
Totally.
What pots,
what a fucking crazy life end.
What's even crazier about it?
There's not a goddamn person I've talked
to that thinks he did anything wrong.
Like what he did was exposed with
careful too.
He was just like,
you know,
let all the journalists that everything
he was just like,
he's make sure that there's no didn't
matter.
No one's being jeopardized.
Not only that,
the whole remember the hope and change
website.
The hope and change website that obama
had wheN he's running for president had
a whole piece in there about supporting
with blowers,
transparency and supporting
whistleblowers when he was persecuted
more than any other president under the
espionage act.
What happens when you get in there?
Did they just show you fucKing ufo
landing on the north pole and what do
they show you?
They show you where all the bombs are
being planted.
I think that yoU're so someone who has,
who is as young and impressionable as
obama that at that time,
I think he was vetted really early when
he was at harvard and I think that um,
he just was so fucking young.
I mean,
what?
He was barely even a senator for a term.
Right.
and he just gets plucked out of
obscurity and catapulted to the
president's ship president ship
precedent ship the presidency.
And then he just surrounded by a bunch
of fucking.
I'm not excusing him at all,
I think is a war criminal.
I really strongly dislike obama.
I think he's like a great manipulator.
A bit of a left.
Everyone,
a little bit of a lefty there.
Astronomy,
martin,
but I definitely think that god,
can you imagine who was just surrounding
him at all times,
like he had hillary clinton barking into
zero mccain like these crazy neo-cons
who are just like,
we need more war and I think that you
saw all the neocon establishment really
promoting obama until the Syria thing
happened where we backed down and that's
where you kind of saw this like
ridiculous schism where now netanyahu's
coming to visit and it's like this
crazy,
um,
where obama's like week now.
So that's been an interesting.
Or they basically were like,
they were pissed off about the Syria
thing really well.
They were like,
look,
we're about to have a civil war in
America.
Yeah,
this could get ugly if they invaded
Syria,
who the fuck knows what would have
happened?
It would have gotten really ugly in this
country.
The most.
Whoever would Be the most dominant
militant force on the ground would rise
to power.
Just like,
well,
I mean look at Libya for fuck sake.
Baster,
total disaster in the past or now.
It's a terrifying place now apparently.
So it was like,
yeah,
no one's.
I don't think anyone's really defending
assad,
but it's about people's sovereignty.
Right.
Amazing.
That a guy like you,
you look at these dictators and you say,
well,
no one wants kadafi to stay in power.
Obviously it's bad to have kadafi there,
and when kadafi got killed,
first of all,
it was one of the most bizarre and
strange moments in social media and in
the power of cell phone videos and the
ability to distribute information.
The fact that they had video of this
guy,
the thing that.
Yeah,
and a moments he's dying,
the like the moments they captured him
and they're all screaming and you're
seeing something that no one has ever
seen before.
No one ever seen a dictator captured by
rebels,
I guess now.
Yeah,
it's happened throughout history.
It's never been documented and then
distributed to everybody.
I mean,
we could all watch and we could watch it
right now.
Jamie could pull it up right now and we
can kick back and just the comfort of
this woodland hills office suite and
watch this fucking guy get bain edited
in his asshole.
Yeah,
and it's.
It's horrifying and especially this
disaster porn that's put out there by
like jay sock and this video and yeah,
I know the us didn't film the video but
it was showed everywhere and we also
released photos of saddam's sons with
all the bullet holes in them on,
on tv and shit.
We're like,
look like,
look what you did that's fucking sick
man.
And,
and you know,
we can see isis videos all day long,
have these crazy hollywood style sets of
where people are getting beheaded and
it's like.
And you get mowed,
jumpsuits and it's like this crazy
fucking manifestation of like hollywood
culture and the military industrial
complex rolled into one,
but at the same time you have our
military uploading every drone strike on
a fucking youtube channel.
What are the,
what the why are including the ones that
kill civilians?
Oh,
aBsolutely.
Yeah.
It's like just in case you're wondering
what we're doing here,
you can watch our youtube channel and
see how the people were killing.
It's really Weird.
Well it's,
It's horrific that when you watched her
decision making,
should we shoot?
Should we shoot?
Let's just shoot like,
well,
it's not like that.
She's like tRying to figure it out on
the fly and then you realize like,
this is what precision drone strikes are
all about.
There's nothing precise about it.
This is not surgical.
It's like you have a bad person that may
or may not be in this area.
You have good information that the bad
persons in this area let the missiles
fly and they fly and then everybody is
anywhere near.
That guy gets fucked up too and we're
Just supposed to accept that because
that's just a bad person.
We need to get them out.
We need to take out the bad person.
If other bad people,
aren't we a bad person?
If we're killing innocent people,
it isn't that the whole idea behind
shit.
I mean it's.
It's good to want to protect us against
bad people,
but that way is bad.
Like that's a bad way,
but you're saying you have a better
word.
No,
I don't have a better way.
I don't have a better way that that.
All I know is that isis has gotten a
shitload of us military equipment and
billions of dollars,
so maybe we should stop just a bit like,
you know,
all of the stuff that we've tried to
train the iraqi army,
like this isn't working because they're
abandoning and like isis is just taking
large swathes of equipment and humvees
and grenade launchers and shit.
So I mean wHen I look at stuff like that
happening,
it's just like we just need to remove
ourselves from the situation and let
like allied states that are in the area
really take hold of whatever
going out the way to do it.
I mean there a.
Is there justifiable war in your eyes?
Like now when you look at it?
Oh you mean in general.
When you look at what's going on with
isis right now,
when they're decapitating,
the syrian head of antiquities and
blowing up these ancient cherished
monuments is they're justifiable war
there.
Are these bad guys?
Can you go in there and stop these bad
guys?
I don't think there is a justifiable war
with isis because isis was created out
of the vacuum of just a large war and
countless casualties and refugees and
the civil war thing that happened there.
So I think that isis is a direct result
of us military intervention.
So I think that more us military
intervention to stop isis is just going
to exacerbate the problem and I
definitely do not think that that should
be,
um,
an option whatsoever.
Right?
But what do you do?
Do you let them take over and just start
doing more?
This is the trick.
This is the trick is like,
it's always going to be something.
first it was all caden.
Now it's like,
now it's like isis is like pulling it
people's heartstrings so much because
they're seeing these crazy images and
it's like,
how can we just sit back and do nothing?
The thing is there's genocides happening
in Congo.
Are we going to go invade and take out
the.
I mean,
it's just like,
why are we picking and choosing what
we're putting in front of the tv screens
and brainwashed and everyone's saying,
what are you,
what are you going to do about isis?
First it was fucking a bolt.
What happened to a bulla that was all
over the fucking tv and we curate it.
Annuity.
There's so much going on.
I just think to hone in on isis and just
say like,
we all need to focus on destroying isis
militarily is,
uh,
is just a farce because a,
it came out of military intervention and
b,
we're not going to fucking destroy isis.
It's just going to galvanize more people
to join isis.
That's why they're recruiting is so high
across the world.
People are just like,
fuck tHis.
I mean they're being drawn to isis
because of the endless warfare going on.
So I just think I don't have the
answers.
I do think that regional players need to
take a step in.
That means Syria.
That means you know,
Iraq,
people in the region that understand the
region are not coming from like this neo
colonial lens and just like all we have
is military solutions because that's all
we fucking know because we're the
fucking empire.
That's right.
Chris got rescued.
I don't think that there's any clear
solution and I think that's a real part
of the problem.
I think that everybody who looks at isis
decapitating decapitated head of
antiquities and blowing up monuments and
lighting people on fire with slow
motion.
Let me just see that video that they did
where they have,
they have slow motion video cameras like
complicated techniques where they're
showing these people getting lit on
fire.
I mean what they're doing is promoting
terror.
They're trying to scare people and
they're doing it with these videos.
Videos of decapitations assassinations.
Isn't it weird that they put them on
youtube,
but it just keeps playing them?
If it bleeds,
it leads as you used to be on the girl.
you know how it is.
Start a new show.
What are you doing?
The empire files starting in the empire.
Final week and a half.
Fucking at counter culture type shit.
What are you trying to do with this
empire?
Files?
Fucking
dissect the empire.
TrY to strip away the layers of the
empire.
How did we get here?
Where do we go from here?
How do we.
MuShrooms.
So it's funny because I'm jumping from
Russia state television to latin
american owned tv.
Who owns this one?
So this is chavez from the grave.
50 one percent Venezuela and then you
have a 49 percent block of like
Argentina and I'll play in Costa Rica
and Nicaragua and stuff.
So it's like a 49 percent owned.
So it's a giant latin american block
that has telesource,
which is the network.
And chris hedges just launched a show on
it and now I'm launching one called the
empire files and it's going to be really
great.
Everyone check it out.
We have all the social media up ready to
go.
So what's the name of,
of network?
Tell us or tell us sor,
sor as you are.
And
uh,
how do you get it?
Do you get it online or do you get it?
Unfortunately,
unlike our tea,
it's not in as many households on tv and
cable,
so you can just watch it on youtube or
if you're in latin America can watch it
until the summer.
So the upload everything to youtube.
Well that's beautiful.
That's all you need.
Exactly.
So you just basically use them for a
studio using using their resources to
help get the information out about the
crazy empire we're living in.
so like what kind of shit you going to
do?
Like investigative reporting type shit
going to fly over to these horrible
places.
So yes.
InvesTigative reporting and crimea.
Crimea.
It's on the ground.
She needs to be on the ground and crimea
for people that don't know.
There was a report that abby was working
for rt,
which is Russia today.
She did this,
a very critical piece on crimea and what
was going on over there in the Ukraine
and they were gonna send her.
They said they were gonna send her to
cry man.
She was like the fuck you are.
I live in America.
Pitch.
Yeah.
Just send all vetted russians and shit
like go over and you're just like,
here's,
you know what I mean?
I could just imagine how it would be.
It would just be like when Jeff
Stevenson,
shane smith went to North Korea and they
like fake restaurant set up for them and
just set it up for you.
I wanted to talk about the anniversary
of the atomic bombs.
Okay,
sure.
Um,
what do you think about that?
Well,
I think it's a fascinatinG moment in
history and an amazing moment for amazes
me more than anything that we haven't
blown up an atomic bomb since 1947.
That's the most amazing thing.
So somehow or another we have had the
brains to go,
like,
what will,
you know,
what is that 60,
70,
66 slash 68 years,
whatever the fuck it is,
60,
68 years without.
And he's put his fucking city.
So it glows in the dark.
That's kind of crazy.
That's amazing.
But what,
what's truly amazing is how much
ignorance was involved in the testing
process.
The,
uh,
the,
the initial bombs that they blew up in
the desert where they had soldiers run
at the bombs.
Did you ever see those videos on a
little like a,
like the thinG where you're looking at a
solar eclipse,
they're just like,
I'm your cardboard glasses kids,
and it's like 10.
Well,
the,
they had these ones where they would
blow up these fake cities and they would
have these guys in a trench.
They would blow up the fixed cities and
thEy would jump out of the trench and
then run towardS the blast,
which never seen that.
Now,
if you can find those,
jamie,
because they're,
they're amazing.
No,
theY didn't do it because they didn't
think it was gonna affect them.
They were teaching them to run towards
the blast.
The idea would be that this nuclear bomb
would go off.
Everybody would be disoriented and
fucked up and that these american gis
would run in there and take over.
These guys all died.
Not only did they die,
but john wayne died.
John the bomb killed john wayne.
If you know that no one knows that nuts,
the bomb killed the fucking greatest
american actor of all time.
It's insane.
The bomb killed the man who played
gangas.
Does everyone realize?
Yeah,
so this is what they would do.
They would all get in these trenches.
I mean,
these are the actual trenches.
it's unbelievable.
it's,
it's horrific that they had these four
fucking soldiers.
yeah.
It was ridiculous.
So they,
these gUys,
they're playing cards and shooter.
Some women just like john mccain and so
they blow these things off and when you
watched the impact,
look at these guys are just ducking
their head and so they have this close
enough that you see the blast,
like super clearly.
So they have these fake bodies out
there.
They're all like drawn japanese likes to
watch how this goes off.
They set it off and then the guys get
up.
Oh my god,
oh my god.
It's right in front of them.
I mean,
what is it?
Fuck five miles away,
six miles away,
whatever it is,
but look at the impact,
hits them and then they're closing their
ears and then they run towards the blast
and those guys are all dead,
all of them,
and they died young.
See the blast hits some.
Look at this.
Oh my god.
This is all nuclear radiation,
intense.
Super high doses of nuclear radiation.
So who knows what happened and then I
mean,
I'm sure a good percentage of them died
of cancer.
A few outlier survive because of freak
genes,
but most of those guys,
just liKe the Gipper,
not the gipper.
What was he?
What was it was john wayne.
Look at that.
They're just running toward it.
Ronald reagan was the gipper.
What was john wayne?
Fucking ridiculous.
My god.
Look at like the.
Not just the plume,
But those crazy late or smoke formations
to the left.
I Don't know what those are.
You don't want.
My favorite one is the one that they did
in the ocean.
Yeah,
the one that they didn't really know how
much of an impact it was going to have.
The fucking just tRied shit,
you know,
just like they tried this,
see if you could find the,
the video of the ocean nuclear
explosions that they did.
I think they did it off of guam.
I think that's where it was.
I don't remember though,
but they,
um,
they had all these battleships that they
stationed around where the bombs would
go off and uh,
when they,
when they did it,
everything got fucked up.
I mean,
everything anywhere near it got fucKed
up.
Go for this.
Look at this.
Look at this comes out of the water.
I mean you're talking about like a mile
of water straight up in the air and just
ignore gulfs that battleship.
Yeah.
That battleship got fucked up.
John lin was the duke,
the duke.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
well,
it went straight up and straight down,
but I'm sure it had incredible
repercussions,
but look at it just they have no idea
they,
I mean,
they didn't want to waste that.
They would try to blow some stuff up
underwater and wonder how close they
could be while it's happening.
Turns out not close.
Well,
here's all know is that the atomic bomb
would obliterate,
like incinerate tens of thousands of
lives in an instant and that takes,
I think it's one of the greatest war
crimes that are perpetrated on humanity
and I think that's one of the greatest
crimes against humanity that's ever been
done.
And whenever I say This,
I went to Japan last year and went to
the hiroshima every museum with like an
in utero blast survivor and it was one
of the most intense museums I've ever
been to because we grew up,
of course.
Yes.
Yeah.
So,
so it was his mother's stomach when she
was right there.
It was just like a random chance that
she just survived and he happens to be
fine.
Um,
but it was such a traumatizing.
It's wicked good hearing his arm
stretch.
Right.
I wish that's what it was like,
um,
it just really,
really horrified museum because we grow
up.
That is probably the biggest myth that
we grow up learning is that the bombs
were necessary to end the war and that
they save lives and it's just like a way
to legitimize a really,
really horrific atrocity.
Um,
two of them actually will.
The issue is that Japan was already
willing to surrender and that we didn't
want them to surrender because we wanted
to try the bombs out.
That's whether or not that's true.
That's the bIg debate and that's
something that a lot of people still to
this day argued back and forth on
whether or not it's actually the case.
if it is the case,
it's even more horrific because just
like what they wanted to do in the ocean
where they tried that bomb out and
watched a mile high wave of water
overcome that fucking battleship.
They wanted to see what happens when you
dropped that shit on a city and they
dropped Russia.
Their cock.
Yeah.
They show.
Well,
I mean it's really,
it's,
it isn't actually up for debate anymore
and this is,
this is a problem.
It's just like the Iraq war.
It's just these people kind of holding
onto this last ditch like gasp of air
just to hold onto like american
exceptionalism and it really just is
totally debunked at this point because
even truman himself instilled an atomic
bomb survey,
university of Colorado featured to and
of just like dozens of american military
experts and leaders,
internal interviews,
diaries,
other declassified materials basically
involved in a bomb decision and all of
them had one unit unanimous commonality
among them that every single one said
the bomb was not a military necessity
and it did not need to happen for the
surrender that Japan was ready to
surrender because if you remember,
I think like 100,000
or maybe 80,000
people were incinerated in tokyo just
weeks prior with the fire bombing.
So the u s had already dropped.
All these bombs basically eviscerated
tokyo and so countless people died way
more.
People actually died.
Then in the initial atomic bomb drops.
So it's just,
it's just a really,
really unfortunate kind of thing that's
perpetuated and people just still hold
onto it.
You know,
they say it would have saved lives.
It's like,
well,
it would have saved us soldiers lives,
but instead it took like probably half a
million japanese.
If you look at the countless maimed in
radiation poisoning,
I mean I think like 80,000
died instantly and with the incineration
was something that yeah,
it's awful.
The only argument that could be said
that it saved lives is that a kept other
people from using nuclear weapons
because there is so horrific.
Otherwise you look at all the war that
has taken place since 1947 and not one
person has used a nuclear bomb.
It could be argued that it was because
how horrific that was when it did happen
with.
That's not a really good argument and
it's also like irritating that the us is
the one fearmongering in the world about
like he can't have a nuclear bomb.
He can.
He can't.
AnD it's like,
well,
you guys are the only ones who have only
used them troll weiss.
So why are we the arbitrators of who and
who cannot utilize nuclear weapons?
Well,
we're righteous and plus we're one
nation under god,
chris [inaudible] and patients.
Do you.
Do you know that we're under god when
you know most people don't even know
that we became one nation under god
after the comedy scare,
the 19 fifties.
Really the mccarthy scares what led
them.
To add that to the pledge of allegiance.
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States,
one nation indivisible for liberty,
and they had one nation under god,
indivisible.
They had to add that to it.
They had to add that to it because of
the kami scare.
That's unreal.
So 19 fifties male.
Yeah.
Before that.
Before the mccarthy hearings,
they.
They didn't have undergone.
Speaking of dirty,
insane,
insane.
What about people that believe in
buddha?
Right.
They don't have the.
It's not under them.
They ain't.
No one needs to be changed it.
Then I Just assume that they're going to
change it again to one nation under
chris kyle is so crazy because it's
like,
I don't think jesse ventura got like
threat saying they're going to cut his
bull.
They did.
No,
he did.
He got a lot of the horrible death.
maybe.
I'm sure if I had to guess,
that's.
I don't know.
Man.
I think there was a lot of like really
don't know what happened though.
So explain the,
the jesse ventura thing,
because a lot of folks aren't aware.
Obviously badass navy seal epic.
Well he was a navy seal was before it
was thought they were both.
There wasn't that.
He wasn't a navy seal.
They used to be,
it was something,
there was another name for like before
know,
because it was in the Vietnam era.
Yeah.
I forget what I'll find out.
So,
so jesse ventura,
I'm total bad ass.
Like the opposite of chris kyle.
Right.
He's like against war.
He's really on point.
So anyway,
chris kyle was ever in a movie slack
drawn.
Is that in front of me?
Yeah.
Um,
so he and chris kyle's book,
it makes up this giant bar fight that he
like beat up jesse ventura.
And if you know who jesse ventura is,
like,
he's fucking like a brick house.
Well he's an older gentleman too.
I mean born in 1951 I think because.
Sure.
But still,
it's like if you're going to fucking go
out there and say that you beat the shit
out of jesse ventura,
you like socked him in a bar,
a might be a bad idea.
Well,
here's what happened.
He in the book,
he
wasn't referred to as jesse ventura.
He was referred to a scruffy.
He called them scruffy and he was saying
that this guy was some celebrity they'd
beat up because this guy had said
something bad about navy seals.
So chris kyle came along and socked him
for America.
He was a udt underwater demolition team
is the original seals.
Um,
so he said oN the opiod,
anthony show that it was chris kyle,
but the,
chris kyle said that it was a jesse
ventura.
That's when he was goated into saying
who the guy was.
I believe it was opening anthony.
I'm pretty sure.
And I'm in that.
That's when jesse ventura said,
what?
You didn't fucking hit me like we didn't
get into a fight.
What are you talking about?
and jesse ventura sued him and won and
won one point $8,000,000.
There it is.
Jesse ventura wins one point 8 million
in damages against chris kyle,
celine,
navy seal sniper,
and here's the issue was that he gave
chris kyle the option to,
to just to,
just to retract it,
admit you're wrong,
and I'll drop the chris.
Carl wouldn't do it.
No fucking.
And then he was killed.
Chris kyle was killed by some,
some poor kid with ptsd.
Poor kid,
asshole murderer.
He's a murderer to another guy that
fucked up.
I mean murdered chris kyle for no
reason.
Said ptsd.
Shot him.
Shot the other guy that was with him,
stole his truck.
I mean he was fucked.
War of that level of that scale
obviously fucks people's head up.
And when he died,
jesse ventura continued with the lawsuit
and that's where he got criticized and
that's you're assuming the widow and all
this shit.
And they said he was suing the book
company.
He said he was.
He goes,
I'm suing everybody that's profiting off
of this lie,
that scully and his take on it was.
PEople also should be aware of the truth
of what this guy not,
didn't just lie about that,
but he lied.
I mean,
jesse ventura did several inteRviews.
We were talking about all the different
lies.
There's more than one line that book.
Absolutely.
It doesn't mean that there aren't
heroes.
It doesn't mean that the military is
bad.
It doesn't mean that there aren't people
that genuinely go into the military like
I'm sure your boyfriend did,
thinking that they're going to do good,
that they have these ideals that they
want to protect.
They want to protect liberty and they
believe in the american way of life and
then you know,
it all gets convoluted because you're
either with us or against us.
You're with us or again,
it's not.
It's not.
That's not us.
What you're doing is not as lies,
aren't us murder's not us shooting
looters,
not us.
Like these people are making.
These decisions are not us.
I mean we have more in solidarity with
the people in Iraq than we do it.
Like the elite that are making these
decisions.
Yeah.
The,
the people that are complete neo-cons
that are complete chicken hawks that are
outside of the consequences of war,
the ones pulling the strings.
I think that there's a big problem with
just the militarization,
our society
where we have,
you know,
every sports game has this giant
military.
I'm just like drama thing going on where
we pay tax payer sponsored fucking
fighter jets flying over the stadiums
and shit.
I mean,
every single thing is militarized.
Um,
and we're,
when we're conditioned in this way to
glorify the military so much that it
becomes an,
especially when you're at the helm of
the empire,
thAt is the largest military force in
the world that's consolidated like
military super power.
That's the only solution to everything.
A bola sending the fucking military
isis,
let's bomb them.
More riots in the streets or like,
you know,
sending the fucking militarize riot cops
who just got trained next to israeli
troops in Bahrain.
It's like,
good god.
I mean we need to start really removing
ourselves with this kind of
militaristic,
I dunno,
characterization of our society because
it's really fucking toxic man.
Well,
and also it creates military problems
abroad because the rest of the world
identifies us with that as well.
Of course,
if we're doing shit like what we've done
in the Iraq war,
which whatever the number is,
whether it's sam harris is number one
that he adheres to or whether it's the
one of the far left adheres to a lot of
fucking people,
right?
A lot of fucking people died and that
those people,
it creates without a doubt,
martyrs and it creates without a doubt,
support for the opposition because we
were looked at in other parts of the
world as the dark empire and also if
they're muslim and they,
they,
they support muslim ideals and then they
see that these people who are have a
completely different faith or attacking
and invading their homeland,
it's pretty easy to support that.
And then they,
it Just piles on and next thing you
know,
we got a problem and we got a current
problem and we have a past problem and
we've got a future problem and we have a
military industrial complex that's just
fucking rakesh and allows problems
because problems means we may get to
make more missiles and more missiles
means mum.
Money keeps going.
I mean money,
more problems.
Did you ever see the hunter s thompson
documentary?
No.
IT's a gonzo.
I think it was called.
No,
it's.
It's great.
It's a great documentary,
but one of the best parts about it was
mcgovern when he was recounting his,
his days with,
with hunter,
when hunter was writing that fear and
loading on the campaign trail and he
followed around the press corps for a
year,
then wrote that book,
but mcgovern was just talking about how
he was just sick and tired of old men in
air conditioned buildings,
making decisions that are to send young
men off to war and I'll just never
forget the way he was saying that.
And he's,
you knoW,
mcgovern when he was doing that thing,
you know,
he was an old guy when they were doing
that documentary.
He died 2012,
but he was,
he was old when they were doing that
documentary and he was just saying,
I'm just tired of it.
I'm tired of.
And he died very shortly after that
documentary was made some of the last
days of his life.
And you know,
he ran for president and was the
seventies [inaudible] 72,
I think 70,
72,
whatever it was,
but it was during the Vietnam war and
just that kind of voice and he didn't
win.
One of the reasons why I didn't win is
because his vice presidential candidate
turned out that he had undergone shock
therapy,
electrical shock therapy,
and kind of hid that from everybody.
And it came out during the campaign,
but he was ahead.
Mcgovern was a head and part of the
reason why he was ahead,
it was because hunter was supporting
them and hunter was writing for the
rolling stone and he would write crazy
shit.
like that was where he wrote about ed
muskie who was also running for
president.
He was saying that ed muskie was
bringing in brazilian doctors and they
were treating him for his ibogaine.
Okay.
Addiction.
I've been addicted to ibogaine scenes.
No one even kneW what it was back then.
Ed muskie was clearly exhibiting signs
and it was really funny because they
interviewed hunter on one of these in
the documentary.
He's on one of these talk shows.
He goes wearing,
well there was a rumor that a ed muskie
was addicted to ibogaine and I started
the rumor,
but he was at journalist,
but it wasn't,
I mean he was a journalist,
but he was also,
he was writing fiction but easily like I
thought everybody knew,
everybody knew it was bullshit.
He's my favorite of all time.
He's one of my favorite people that ever
lived and uh,
he just,
he knew it was bullshit and,
but he thought it was.
Other people knew it was bullshit,
but he also knew that he could make an
impact with this.
So he thought that he thought that
muskie was just fucking ridiculous hack.
So he just mocked him and,
and talked about him being under the
throes of this addiction that they had
brought in this brazilian doctor and,
and then musky,
like have these breakdowns on the
campaign trail because he was dealing
with.
Because nobody had ever dealt with that
kind of negativity from the press
before.
Nobody ever running for president had
dealt with just someone fabricating
craziness about them.
And it's the pressure of this.
You could tell he wasn't.
I don't even know where to start.
If you run for president and you don't
have a thick skin,
if you can't deal with people getting
mad at you on twitter,
making shit up about you and the huff
post or whatever they would want to do
you.
You really shouldn't be running for
president.
You have to develop some sort of rhinos
scan at this point,
but back then they were paper.
That was.
People didn't know what the fuck to do.
There's only been a few presidents that
were on tv and they don't have the
billion dollar campaigns where they're
like,
have a spin master training.
When you think about 1972,
how many fucking presidential candidates
had even been on television?
You know,
jusT a few decades worth.
It was so recent.
It was all so fucking recent.
These poor bastards didn't know what to
do.
Now,
look at it.
Now.
Look at this fucking dog and pony show.
Now you get obama doing the mark marin
podcast,
which are super crazy.
Isn't it bizarre?
Yeah.
Just go right to her.
No,
I listened to a little bit of it.
I didn't listen to him.
Oh,
just knew it was all going to be soft
balls and bullshit and all boat,
you know,
America.
You just funny where obama's going for
the audience.
It's like advice,
you know,
sitting down with shane smith and Mike
Moran.
I mean they,
he has good people telling them where
people are at that come in here and
smoke a joint wIth me.
Barack obama down fucking scared
podcasts.
Do mushrooms experience sue just a
little mushrooms runs child's play
compared to compare to this?
Well,
I don't know if I would do it.
I would feel weird about it.
I mean I would definitely do it if you
want to do it,
but it wouldn't pursue it and if I.
But I just don't know what you could
ever get out of that.
like what you.
You're never going to get trained like a
vader.
You know what I mean?
Like everything you'd say would just be
going on.
You would had some serious fucking
enemies if you really went for it.
Like that is the last person in the
world you want to like put a.
You want to put you in a book or a
category,
right?
Like this is.
he's on the fuck with lists.
I traveled too much in the world.
arguably right up there.
The most powerful figurehead in the
world,
if not the most powerful.
Certainly top four or five.
Just thought of something really fucking
crazy.
The bomb that we stopped being an atomic
bomb that those obviously dropped on
hiroshima and nagasaki.
We have.
That's Like fucking babysit.
Oh,
hydrogen?
Yeah.
Thirty 300 times stronger.
I don't even.
I don't even understand.
Thirty $300.
what would that even do?
Like picture what we just saw exploding
that little battleship.
Like what the fuck?
Well,
how do we have that?
I don't know.
I mean,
I guess we want to kill better.
Better at it.
The more fucked up is the research
they've done into anti-matter weapons.
Ooh,
that's really crazy.
Because we don't know whether or not
that's the.
This is just theoretical guy.
Bring me one of them.
Alcohol beverages to young jamie.
Um,
we don't know whether or not it's
theoretical or whether this is actually
a proof of concept.
Whether anti-matter can be developed
into a weapon,
we do know there's research being done
on it and when they do develop
anti-matter research,
I mean when they do develop anti-matter
weapons,
whether it's in our lifetime or in the
future lifetimes,
you're talking about a world destroyer.
We're talking about something they might
just shoot over at pluto like,
you know,
it'll take nine years and we'll watch
pluto blow up from the sky just to see
if we can do it.
That's very possible.
They might do that someday.
Just decided to launch it in some
fucking planet.
Well,
do you know that that's your
justification for continuing the
trillion dollars that they're going to
spend just updating and refurbishing the
nuclear arsenal is that they keep
doubling down on the fucking star wars
fantasy that reagan had.
Gorbachev went
to reagan and he was like,
let's disarm.
Let's fucking end it.
And reagan was like,
no,
I'm senile and I want to create this
giant star wars program that's going to
like,
you know,
like the shield and the sky and we're
going to do this and that.
And everyone was like,
all right,
never going to fucking work.
And of course it didn't.
But that's still like a dress of
vacation to battle asteroids to have
these nuclear weapons here and continued
to.
Yeah.
Video game,
asteroids out when you know,
they say that if you do blow up an
asteroid,
the real issue is you're going to create
more asteroids.
Just mass.
Like you have a,
you have,
you have something,
you don't relate it.
If you have something that has masked,
it's five miles across,
you're going to develop a 100,
you know,
half mile ones or whatever you know,
or 500 yard ones and they're going to
kill everybody to.
They're going to come down.
It's going to rain metal and rock from
the sky.
Do you mean people that don't know what
an asteroid is?
A lot of them are iron.
They're metal,
they're just giant chunks of metal and
you fucking space.
It's a trip where here's a great theory
for her.
Great conspiracy.
That is actually true.
Fuck,
go ahead.
Go ahead.
Yeah,
we're good.
Go ahead.
Just do your p and we'll have jamie pull
this up to pull up.
I want you to pull up this star wars
scientists that have been killed,
star wars scientists that have either
been murdered or committed suicide
because what's really fascinating about
the star wars program,
and I'll have to at least slightly
reiterate this,
when young abby martin gets back because
I don't think she was completely aware
of this,
but when the star wars weapons defense
system was created,
the idea behind it was the United States
was going to create a military.
They were going to create some sort of a
military solution with satellites that
could shoot these missiles out of the
sky.
Now while they were doing it,
they were spending fuck loads of money
on this and apparently it was never
effective and if you could pull up the
numbers,
just pull up like there's a list of all
the star wars.
See if he could find a better article.
See like that.
Who killed all the star wars scientists
here.
See if you could find out who go to a
like a rent is rents legit.
Ariana see isn't like a super conspiracy
website,
mysterious deaths of scientists like
scientists killed,
star wars scientist murdered,
killed,
but a giant number of them have all been
killed.
Let's see.
I don't know,
like,
what's a good,
what's a good like website for this?
We should probably find a good one
because there's so many fucking goofy
conspiracy theory websites that lumped a
star wars people in with um,
chem trails.
So the,
the star wars program,
the,
the theory being the star wars program
has apparently never really effective.
And the scientists that were behind the
star wars program,
a fuck load of them died by suicide,
by murder.
And there's a giant list of them and
it's one of the most fascinating
conspiracies,
modern time to find it.
Okay.
Um,
these guys that knew the people that
knew the scientists,
the engineers dead,
like almost all of them,
they all died like murdered suicide and
like very,
very suspicious.
And someone did like a number,
like,
you know,
they did like a percentage,
like what are the odds that all these
people were murdered inside of billion
to one?
Yeah.
Well,
they knew,
they all knew that it was bullshit it
star wars program.
They'd spend millions,
untold billions of dollars to develop
this completely ineffective system to
shoot missiles at a sky.
It was never proven to work ever.
And those scientists are all dead of
food.
Here it goes.
Dead scientists.
And look at us.
There's the list mark coney scientists
mystery,
the 19 eighties over two dozen science
graduates and experts working on the
marconi or plessy.
How do you say that?
Plessy pls,
cc plus sss.
Why defense systems died in mysterious
circumstances,
most appearing to be suicides.
The mod denied.
These scientists had been involved in
the classified star wars projects and
that the desks were in any way
connected.
But look at how these guys died.
I'm look at this guy,
computer programmer.
I'm keith bowden,
scientists and uh,
at essex university engaged in work for
marconi,
bubba blah,
circumstance of death,
fatal car crash was vehicle went off out
of control across a dual carriageway and
plunged into a disused railway lines.
Mean didn't even drinking witH family
and friends.
Denied the allegations.
So what the fuck was it were?
Where's the autopsy?
Coroner report,
accident.
Here's another one.
Literally a lieutenant colonel anthony,
godly expertise,
head of work study unit at the royal
college of military science,
circumstance of death disappeared
mysteriously without explanation.
I presumed that that's fucking
expertise.
Radar designer and droughts,
men draftsman,
I guess as draftsman droughts,
men with marconi,
circumstance of death,
death by shotgun,
blast at home corners,
verdict,
suicide.
jonathan walz,
29 expertise digital communications
expert who had worked at gdc and had
british telecom,
secret research center at the blah blah,
blah,
blah.
Here's his light.
Yep,
exactly.
Deiter result of falling from a hotel
room in west africa working for british
telecom.
He had expressed fears that his life was
in danger,
corners,
verdict,
open,
and it just goes on and on and on.
Look out.
you see how?
See scrolling,
look how's as jamie's growing,
look at the upper right hand corner.
Look how fucking long this list is like.
Scroll down to the bottom of this list
so you can see how many people were on
this.
Oh my god.
Look at this.
This is all a lot of people that were
attached to the star wars program,
all of them in the late eighties and the
early nineties,
dead as fuck.
Kramer,
David Kelly [inaudible],
the guy who basically said that there
were no wmds and jen and he found it was
found dead.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
That's fucking sketch does a lot of
those people.
That's what happens with the people are
like interested in going over to some
place that we don't belong.
Killing people.
The idea that you're not going to kill
you because you want to stop them from
killing people like crazy.
that's crazy talk.
It's a very good way to say.
How about pat tillman?
I mean there's pat tillman's brother
believes that pat tillman was killed
because he was speaking it because it
was a very public figure and then you
speaking out against them.
You know,
that's going back to the chris kyle
thing because every single myth that has
been resurrected out of the Iraq
invasion has been like,
you know,
the pat tillman thing,
they were so hard,
hard on for pat tillman because he
really was a fucking here.
I mean he's abandoning like a million
dollar career to go fight him because he
really believed it and he's really
fucking smart and he realized that it
was based on lies and shit and he had
this diary and it's an incredible
documentary that just talks about his
transition and people who knew him and
when he was changing his mind and he had
this diary all written up and they
fucking burned it.
Dude,
when they killed him,
if they did,
they say it was friendly fire,
who knows?
But his brother thinks that it was
targeted.
I don't know,
but he definitely would have come out
and been like another,
like chomsky,
like he would have come out and said he
would have been a figurehead against the
war and he died from friendly fire and
then they burned all of his shit.
They burned his diary so we could set
that is fucking crazy.
And then look at the Jessica Lynch
thing.
Remember her?
Yeah.
And they said she was raped and all of a
sudden then she was like,
the rocky,
like military was like helping her just
put it on in a hospital.
And like taking care of her,
then they've staged that whole,
like
the narrative was that she was trapped
and she was being kidnapped by the
iraqis and that the United States
military went in and rescued her and she
was his hero and she was paraded around
on television,
but she spoke out against it and she got
death threats and she essentially
vanished and she just went quiet on it
and they never talked to her again.
It's so sad too,
because they chose her.
They're like,
we're going to prop you up as this
person.
And it's like,
what are you?
She just got swept up in it.
It's just so crazy the idea that they
would just do that to someone and,
and,
and force them into some sort of a
situation like that,
you know,
I just don't understand why they would
think that you would just play along.
I guess they just assume like we're
goiNg to kill people or they're telling
you to do this or telling you to do
that.
And it was one of the first times that
we had women in active duty two and you
know,
in,
in combat duty.
Yeah,
totally.
Just not a lot of.
I mean,
when you're,
when you're dealing with death and
you're dealing with what you would call
a sanctioned murder,
right?
I mean that's what like if,
if you're in the military and you are
supposed to go over there and shoot some
bad guys,
whether they're good or bad guys,
you're going to go murder those people.
Right?
That's sanctioned murder and it's one of
the weirdest things about civilization
is that we salute sanctioned murder.
Murder is awful when you don't like
someone and you killed them.
We want to lock you up.
But if we tell you you can kill someone
as long as it's written down on paper.
And we all collectively agree,
but we don't really collectively agree.
That's where it gets weird as a small
group of people that decide who you can
and can't kill and then everybody else
has to fall in line.
Well,
if those people were beyond reproach,
if they were these incredibly
enlightened people that had only our
best wishes and hopes in mind and could,
could not make a bad decision,
but then it makes sense to just give
into them.
They're smarter than us.
We're the ants and they're,
they're the,
they're the geniuses and we'll just
follow along.
But that's not the case.
It's never been there.
No,
and the thing that bothers me about the
obama administration is that he,
he's famed as this like transparency
president.
You know,
we talked about the whistleblower thing.
It's like everything is the opposite of
what it is.
It's like this,
our wellington new era where you have
the nsa's spying now,
like the patriot act sunsetted.
We think that the patriot acts over.
It wasn't,
it was just that the clause that they
were able to illegally spinus through
the nsa in the patriot act expired,
and then they just passed a new law to
basically codified legal spine just
through another caveat.
It's called the freedom act,
so that,
and you can't vote against the patriot
act either because the name is just
like,
what?
You're not a patriot,
you don't like freedom,
but you don't want to answer not,
not freedom.
Yeah,
nope.
Who do you want?
You want death,
what do you want?
Destruction.
So it's like,
wow,
the prisoner to pass the freedom act
like,
yeah,
of course we'd been torturing people.
There's been wars,
there's been extrajudicial
assassinations but never before has it
been like openly codified and like
legislated executively.
You know what I mean?
So it's almost this weird era of
normalization and conditioning where
people just accept this as a new normal,
like the empire and just the post nine
slash 11 era.
We just do these thiNgs now and it's all
legal,
right?
It's illegal because we've created all
these legal caveats to do them.
So what is legal?
That's when it gets weird.
It's just like what is legal and what's
not legal?
They write it down.
It's legal tender pentagram just issued
this field manual to basically for all
the branches in the military and in it.
I guess because citizen journalism is on
the rise and it's really hard to
distinguish like who is like an official
established journalist are not are who's
like embedded with the enemy and they
basically said that journalists can be
killed legally now by a us military
personnel.
That crazy.
Yeah.
That's in the new pentagon arms.
Well that was one of the things that
happened during the obama obama
administration that,
that they started at assassinating
american citizens without trial.
You know,
if they were to due process and you
know,
the rule of law and as long as you're
over there though,
they can just assassinate you drone
strikes.
What,
how is this?
It's I,
I get it.
If they're absolutely honest and beyond
reproach and the most enlightened beings
in the world that are dictating what
these actions would be.
I mean if you have some fucking hitler
character over there and you want to
assassinate him,
I get it.
That makes sense to me.
You know,
you want to us in the loop and be like,
look,
this guy's hitler.
two point.
Oh,
is black and classified Mrs.
Martin.
he didn't.
You work for Russia when you boot on the
ground that continues as a tax against
him.
Like john,
he's barely paying attention.
He had his aide do that while you're
still in the middle of poker.
Yeah.
He doesn't know how to tweet.
Probably barely.
Seaweeds.
Do you think he tweets?
I don't think.
I don't think obama tweet either.
Tweets now.
It doesn't actually touch this key.
I would hope he has better shit to do.
That was obama's tweeting emoji.
Smiley face.
Imagine obama tweeted,
just as there's only a smiley face,
a pile of dog shit.
And uh,
god,
what does that mean?
That's my life.
What does it mean?
Everybody would dissect it forever.
When They look back at us in the future,
when they,
you know,
civilizations 100,
200 years from now,
look back at what were,
you know,
when we look back at world war ii,
looking at these people that were
running towards this bomb,
now we look at him like,
fuck man,
these poor bastards.
You.
What are they going to think about us?
When is that going to not be the case?
Yeah,
I don't,
I dunno,
I was just thinking the other day about
like,
you know,
reality tv and how back in the day we
had like the fat lady at the circus and
like the bearded lady,
it's just like we'd still have that.
It's just in,
in the realm Of reality television.
We're trying to empathize with like this
fat lady,
but really we're just watching like a
giant whale,
live her life and,
and like it's just like the circus and
it's the same with um,
you know,
horror movies and shit,
like we don't have the coliseum but we
still like people being ripped limb from
limb and blood and fucking guts.
It's something about us and,
and yeah,
it's evolved through technology but it's
still that weird innate human trait that
I don't really understand.
Yeah.
We love oddities and we also love people
suffering when we're not because we're
good.
I'm not there.
Yeah,
right.
Like,
let's wait,
like I'm watching intervention because
I've watched the sunshine,
the episode of the girls doing the
duster and I'm like,
alright,
I guess I don't feel bad about smoking
weed because.
Yeah.
Have you ever seen that?
Fucking my strange addiction does this
shit exists in the third world are.
Fuck,
that's a good question.
I don't know.
It's a very good question.
I wonder what what it is about human
beings that when everything is great and
you have too much resources and it's too
easy to get food,
we just start getting really fucking
strange.
I'm addicted to eating dry wall.
I mean that's what I want to know.
I'm wondering,
you know like it almost seems like the,
my strange addiction one is like almost
like,
well having worked in reality tv and
knowing how much of it is bullshit,
how,
how does that work?
Because it just super shit will.
even when,
when I did that saifai show,
they fucking just fake things like your
reaction shots and shit.
I always wonder if you're like,
people are like,
they definitely edit things and put
certain reaction things where they
don't,
where they didn't belong.
To just have to face the way he's
looking at what.
There was one where they did without a
sci fi show that I did where they.
There's a thing that people believe in
called sky quakes,
and this is probably bullshit,
most likely,
but sounds from the sky,
like a crazy like horns and people
trying to figure out what these sounds
were.
Well,
they took a video.
This is one guy sending this video where
he was just.
It was actually,
it's really hilarious because the one
guy that they put the video,
he was like a chem trail believer,
so he believes in a different kind of
bull shit and he was pointing at the sky
and we kind of mocked him for his camp
trail beliefs,
but then these fucking dummies that made
the show that the editors took a chunk
of this guy's video and then added some
sound to it and then put it on the show
and said that he was pointing to a sky
quick,
but he wasn't.
it was just fate and I found out about
it.
I freaked out.
I had them remove it from the show,
but it aired the first time it aired.
That was on the show and then after it
aired,
when they aired it for a second time,
they removed it.
So disingenuous.
That's what they do and that's what they
do.
That's what those shows are.
Those shows are just bullshit and most
of those shows are bullshit.
And saifai at the time had a ton of
those.
There was one show that was all about a
family that was trapped in a house in
Maine because there was werewolf's
outside and it was a whole like fucking
half hour show about these people just
will,
you know,
I looked out my salt,
it was standing up and it looked like a
man,
but it was covenant for just making
things up and that was the whole shit.
They don't give a fuck as long as they
could get that toyota truck commercial
on a toyota.
Then we got tied and then we got a
fucking hot dogs.
Alright,
go back to the werewolf stories.
I understand joe because I had an agent
for a little while looking for work and
stuff and every single thing because I
guess I come from like the same,
you know,
questioning government narratives and oh
shit,
you're a tinfoil hat where if you
fucking question where the government
tells you,
and so it's always these shows.
They're like,
we're starting to show to basically
dissect like jfk and chem trails and
like,
isn't there anything else fucking
happening other than like that same five
fucking things that you guys want to
create shows around?
it's so weird.
No,
there's not.
No.
That's what all these god damn things
are and it's all just bullshit.
It's like,
why don't we talk about shit that
fucking matters are like interesting
stuff that's going on now because those
things are like,
they can start fires,
you know,
it's like you could start fires with the
flint and in a,
you know,
a piece of metal clink,
clink,
clink and they know it works.
So they just keep going to it over and
over again.
You can start a fire with bigfoot,
put big foot on tv and people,
oh look good,
and they're just drawn to it loses a
ufo.
It says it's real.
There's just certain subjects that
people will always want to believe and
they want to believe in psychics.
They want to believe in chem trails,
ufo the government experiments,
the mind control.
Don't you know about majestic twirl
government was there.
I'm sure there's been some mind control
experiments.
There was definitely those lsd dude,
mk ultra where they were just watching
people fucking like a,
like a whorehouse and liked like dosing
them with acid and then these fbi agents
would sit behind like one way mirrors
and just watch him operation midnight
climate in that class.
It must be really cool to be an fbi
agent during the fucking.
They dose people with acid.
When they went to whorehouses guys went
to whore houses.
They would slip acid in their drink and
you know,
they really didn't really want to sex
anymore.
Thinking about life,
existential angst is really kind of true
that the us government has like half the
world is lsd.
Is that,
is that a bullshit?
Well,
it's most likely bullshit.
Here's why it's bullshit because lsd as
a half life and it doesn't last.
If you have a,
a vat of lsd and you leave it in your
house for 10 years and most likely it's
not really effective after aWhile,
so them having that,
they seized a bunch of it.
Really good asset during that whole
time,
but I guess yeah,
sure they did.
Yeah,
but it wouldn't unless they figured out
some way to contain it.
Vacuum seal it in some special way.
I don't know.
I'm guessing.
No,
as far as I know of,
I don't think like,
I think a lot of substances or just not.
That's why vitamins,
if you get vitamins,
like most vitamins,
you look at them,
they're not really effective after like
six months or a year to become less and
less effective over time.
Right.
pretty sure that's the case with lsd.
Don't quote me on though,
but I know it is with weed I've gotten.
yeah.
Unfortunately it doesn't last.
It's like life.
You got to get it fresh and young.
Get that carbon in the fucking possible.
Yeah,
even edibles,
they go bad.
Even if they break them down into a
cookie,
put that cookie in a piece of plastic,
try to eat it.
A couple years from now we'd we just.
So we just took this epic road trip and
got back this morning,
which was amazing that I.
I wanted to tell your audience about the
Utah thing because it was so funny.
I mean here you are in these fucking
massive like rock formations carved by
millions of years of water,
sandstone,
fucking whatever.
Like slate all this shit insane.
Like anyone who has not been to Utah,
you need to go.
Bryce canyon national park is one of the
most absurd things I've ever.
It's like these things called the
hoodoos that are just carved over
millions of years at the stone.
Anyway.
Arches national park obviously that
iconic,
like all the,
the orange arches that are carved in
millions of years like we can carbon
date them.
We know the geological processes very
easy to explain through science.
So we're reading the official park
literature and I'm just like,
man,
I'm like so,
so fascinated.
Like how did this form?
AnD so like crazy and it makes you just
like,
appreciate time.
Like that's what the desert is like.
you fucking appreciate time.
Like that is as you look at that.
And that's the top of the grand
staircase,
joe.
That's the newest part of the grand
staircase.
That's amazing.
So in,
that's fucking ridiculous.
It looks like a standing army.
Yeah.
A few people that are just listening to
this.
what would it looks like?
Obviously it's not,
but it looks like something that someone
has designed.
Looks like something someone carved out
of the stone.
Like some of those things look like
insane.
Yeah.
They look like columns in a building.
It's amazing dude.
Um,
and so in you,
so this is all Utah of course,
named after some mormon guy named bryce
who discovered it,
you know,
so anyway,
there's arches arches that are created
by just wind and time.
That's what you like the most.
The most crazy thing aboUt being out in
the desert for as long as you,
you're just like,
this took millions of years to,
to happen.
I mean,
it makes you just appreciate fucking
time and evolution and like how the
earth has changed and this is only think
about how old the earth is.
BillioNs of years old.
this was only the last couPle of
million.
If you look at something called the
black canyon,
which is actually way deeper than the
grand canyon and way more narrow.
I was just like,
oh my god,
this must have taken billions of years
to form.
And it was just like,
nope,
just the last 2 million years just
popped up.
It's like,
what the fuck?
It just makes you,
it just makes you just appreciate like
time,
time and geology and science.
So anyway,
and this official park literature and
arches,
it explains everything very,
um,
precisely at the very end of it.
It's just like,
okay,
we just explained how all this worked.
This is the history of arches national
park.
And then it says probably all of the
evidence is circumstantial.
And I was just like,
what the fuck?
I was like,
whaT do you mean?
All the evidence is circumstantial.
It's like all the evidence is not
circumstantial.
Evidence is proven.
We know how old these rocks are,
we know exactly what's carved them.
We can test all the sediments,
we can test all the rocks.
So I was just like,
holy shit.
Like has the mormon lobby just lobbied
all the fucking parks in Utah,
which are the best parks in the country
and the most amazing state.
And basically forced them to say,
none of this is real.
It was 14 years old.
He found golden tablets containing the
last work of jesus.
The israeli people came over from the
bering strait and siberia.
That's crazy.
That's the narrative for the mormons.
Do you know that,
that the lost tribe of Israel with the
native americans,
you didn't know that they even tested.
This guy was as rich mormon dude tested
native american dna to try to prove that
they were israeli and that they were the
lost tribes of Israel.
And turns out that's not true from
siberia.
They came over from the berIng strait
and we've known that forever,
but they,
uh,
they tested it.
But in a of Joseph Smith,
he found magic tablets and he had a
magic stone and he could.
He had a seer stone and only he could
read the magic that he wouldn't let
anyone else see them.
Trust me.
Well,
not only that,
he got game needed a stone to look at
them guys.
Seer stone got it serious.
It's a wonderful story.
A wonderful stone.
I wish I had one.
Two angels came and took the tablets
away because the people didn't believe
the test.
Our faith like dinosaur bones,
they're just like,
just got to trust in joseph smith's seer
stones.
Fucking batshit crazy,
dude.
Can you imagine him?
Just wondering,
can you imagine Joseph Smith today
walking around with a seer stone being
like,
I found these golden tablets.
well,
what's really wonderful is that a
follower,
this jackass almost became president.
Got real.
Goddamn.
That's fucking batshit crazy.
The people that don't even know how bad
shit.
Mitt romney,
mitt romney's family is living in
Mexico.
His family is all from Mexico.
That's why his dad was never president.
Mitt romney's dad wanted to be
president.
Mitt romney's family was one of the
fucking mormons that escaped America.
When they made polygamy illegal,
they will like,
look,
I need more than one poser.
Oh god,
it's too much this.
It's true.
That's what happened.
Do you know that?
Didn't know that.
Mitt romney's family,
they still live in Mexico.
Mitt romney's dad is from fucking
Mexico.
He was born in Mexico.
There's a huge white looking will
american from the escape back when there
was nO cars.
Got it.
See,
there was no cars and back when there
was no cars.
You're on a horseback in America.
You're on horseback in Mexico.
What difference does it make?
But if you cross this dirt wind,
you could fuck nine different chicks and
live in a house where you,
you know,
you all have your own rules.
Well,
to this day they're over there.
There's a whole colony of them and
they're at war on a regular basis.
There's mitt romney's cousin over there
in Mexico.
That's kelly romney.
They're playing golf with fucking armed
guards because the cartel kidnaps them
all the time.
Your wives waiting inside,
well,
they get kIdnapped by the cartel war.
These people,
they have these ranches and their arm to
the dick.
Yeah.
She's aware of it that way.
I don't owe this advice.
Is shane over their areas wandering
around in Mexico actually has a really
interesting story because he at bain
capital when he ran bain capital,
um,
he was taken in and trained by monsanto
executives and he,
he like,
I think he was given his first big loan
by monsanto executive.
Then he was like,
all right y'all,
you guys are fucking toxic chemical
company,
fucking agent orange,
all this shit.
Real bad,
real bad.
look,
why don't we shift this over to food
now?
So like he basically was behind this
giant pr push to switch monsanto over
from chemicals to biotech,
which is really interesting to be like,
why was mitt romney's in the fold?
You know,
it's just like super weird that he was
just like right there in the wings kind
of helping foster this transition is
super weird.
People witH money paying capital,
harvesting money.
That's what he says in some commercial
for bain capital.
He was like,
we harvest and money,
like,
oh my god,
how do you show us where the money tree?
I can't.
It's near the golden tablets.
Need a seer stone to see the magIc money
tree seeds only through this tiny seeds.
We water it with angel tiers and piss
fuck money tree harvest.
What are you doing?
Cash.
mit?
It sounded like he was harvesting human
beings.
It's like we grow that planned
parenthood goes and for us the whole
thing is ridiculous.
Hilarious.
Yeah.
The planned parenthood thing,
we were talking about it earlier in a
different podcast.
We were trying to figure out what the
fuck was going on with them.
What are they supposed to fucking do?
Throw the baby's in the trash case.
What?
I said,
yeah,
like I would like them to you if they
are,
if abortion is legal and I think it
should be.
What are they going to do with the
tissue?
Wouldn't it be better if that tissue
gets used,
but it's a fucking super disturbing
video when they start going through the
parts and you realize what abortion
really is like,
oh,
this is in canadian.
Yeah.
More convenient for me to think that
this is a bundle of cells don't really
want to see.
The whole thing is just like,
yeah,
it's like abortion is legal and I would
rather have them utilize the tissue for
something that's scientific instead of
just throwing the garbage can.
So yeah,
that's.
That's true.
I think what a lot of people were
worried about,
not just this is that they were going to
somehow or another influence people to
do it for money influence people to have
abortions for money.
Oh god,
that's insane.
It is,
but it isn't.
There's got to be people that are
willing to have an abortion for money.
What dId they get paid?
Like?
Planned parenthood wasn't the whole
issue that planned parenthood was making
money,
selling the tissue,
but then they said that that wasn't
true.
Something along those lines.
If there was like some black market
thing where people can have abortions
and like sell the tissue,
I just don't.
Yeah,
it's super confusing because the video
implies that planned parenthood was
profiting off of it and that this woman
was trying to say that she could sort of
structure it so they can make more
money.
Look,
all I know is planned parents fucking
great.
Okay.
I,
I love it.
I think it gets important.
Right?
And people wHo want to talk shit.
Um,
planned parenthood isn't talk about this
baby thing.
It's just so ridiculous because I didn't
have healthcare for like three months
after I quit tea and I
was on birth control and I was just
like,
what the fuck would I do?
What would I do if planned parenthood
wasn't here,
I wouldn't have helped them control.
How about working for somebody other
than Russia extends your benefits.
There's some shit that you need
prescribed.
You don't have unemployment.
Broken for lunch.
Just go fucking up certain birth
controls at this,
at the convenient store.
It was rush limbaugh that killed rush
limbaugh's career,
wasn't it?
We was talking about some girl beer.
See that too,
but he was talking about some girl being
a slut because she wanted birth control,
so college student member,
that was like 2012.
That was the dropoff.
That was where it ended for rush limbo.
Oxy didn't do it.
That did it.
Yeah.
He was seeing a bunch of really rude
shit.
Boys probably oxford out of his fucking
head while you're saying it,
you know,
are coming in your nose,
but that,
that literally like ended his career.
That was like aRound 2012,
if I remember correctly.
I'm trying to remember what the story
was,
but it was some college girl and he was
calling her a slut and I think it was a
rape victim or no,
no,
no.
I think it wAs even over the top rush.
Chris commerce.
I think what he wanted to do was he
wanted to.
He was mocking her because she was
saying that a birth control should be a
part of something.
See if he could find that rush limbo
college girl slot birth control.
Google that,
right?
Yeah.
It was like he was.
She was saying that it should be a part
of her health care.
I think he was calling her a slut
because she wanted birth control.
Right?
Like what?
Thirty?
What the fuck,
man,
you wanted to get pregnant.
You dumb.
Fuck.
Exactly.
Oh,
she shouldn't have sex.
Some state just issued free birth
control.
Did this radical idea where they gave
free birth control to women and portion
like fucking plummeted,
like 30 percent,
like teen pregnancy plummeted.
It's like,
wow,
who fuck it.
Fuck it.
Airbrushed.
Limo co's,
georgetown student yet let's not get a
video.
Let's see what the.
With the actual facts work,
I want to go ahead and play it.
Play the audio good
for two days.
Rush limbaugh has a visceral sandra
fluke on the radio.
What does it say?
College coeds.
Susan fluke.
Sandra goes before a congressional
committee and essentially says that she
must be paid to have sex.
What does that make her pain?
Eps.
It makes you a slut,
right?
When you say to a prostitute,
she wants to be paid to have sex.
fluke.
A third year law student at georgetown
is now the flashpoint in a debate about
whether employers should be required to
fully cover contraception.
Even if they have religious jack.
How truncate she wants to get
paid to have sex.
That was it.
That was basically it for him.
That fucking killed him.
That guy has done.
It's really fascinating because rush
limbo was,
oh yeah,
he's darling.
Oh yeah.
His career is dropped off radically.
He's in like third,
fourth tier markets beheaded.
Whoa.
Comment.
like it was like that bad with that guy.
That guy.
He's always putting sros.
Yeah,
but yeah,
that was just.
He was trying to be funny and stupid.
russia's trying to like push his
ideology,
but that killed that guy,
that guy,
like advertisers fleed him in mass after
that.
That's what did it.
Not the rampant racism and what is just
what he was also calling for drug
addicts to be like.
There was a guy who got prosecuted.
I forget what the story was,
but a guy who got prosecuted for some
drug related offense and the.
The fucking judge literally told him
when he was sentencing him that he was
listening to rush limbaugh on the way
over and how Russia was saying that we
have to give drug abusers a wake up call
and that drug abusers need to know that
there's consequences for their actions.
So because of this I'm going to fucking
sentence you for x amount of blah blah,
blah,
blah.
And the guy got released because of
overcrowding.
I read it online.
I forget where I read it from either
drug abusers really,
but this was right before rush got
popped for julian,
like 90 oxies a day and having his
fucking made go out and buy him forum
under assumed names.
She's wearing a fake mustache.
so good.
And she's buying.
This guy was like talking about this
crazy shit on the radio while he was
popping pill is how it is,
man.
All the anti gay people only have the
gay prostitutes.
it's like,
why are you so obsessed?
We were playing ted cruz earlier on the
earlier podcasts and I was like,
I recognize sounds okay.
There's certAin sounds I recognize right
when you.
When you hear a,
do you think of a big black man?
Right?
When ted cruz talks,
I hear a gay man.
I hear a gay man is how he.
Why is he talking?
Let's hear.
Let's hear ted cruz because he's gay.
I think he's gay.
He's super conservative,
super conservative,
but my thought is this guy cannot
fucking wait to get done talking.
just run up thrawn some women's clothes
and suck some cock.
He just sounds gay.
Now.
I don't know if he's gay,
but I've never met anybody.
That sounds great.
It's not gay,
so nothing wrong with being gay.
I want to say this again because I sit
on the earlier podcasts.
There's nothing wrong.
I'd love gay people,
but I don't like is people are gross.
We just don't like or homophobes and
today is that we need to reassemble the
reagan coalition.
We need to bring together all of the
different parts that comprise big 10
about liberals who got elected
president.
You'd be their president when we can say
to them,
well but,
but listen,
there are different elements.
So you've got,
for example,
you've got to bring together and
libertarians,
you've got differing views but shared
values.
Okay.
That's about as straight as he's ever
sounded.
Find a better one.
But it's same sex marriage ruling
because there's a same sex marriage
ruling.
He's trying to fucking straighten it up.
He's lIke,
I don't want to be confused with any of
those.
The guy sounds gay.
I don't know if he is gay.
There's nothing wrong with being gay,
but he sounds gay.
I'm just saying it and people could say,
I sound gay to go ahead and say it.
I don't give a fuck.
The world is on fire.
Comments to route them.
Fire.
Here we go.
And I will tell you,
you are a major celebrity there.
Yeah.
Well it's a very small state.
I mean it was
impressive.
I mean I was earning major script street
cred.
I mentioned to a couple of folks I was
going to be on your show.
They were blown away.
That sounds totally.
He sounds totally different than any
nation.
Being naked with a fucking apron on
baking.
Wow.
Baking and sucking cock.
That's what ted cruz is best.
Those two things that he does,
cupcakes and cock suck,
and that's it should be this campaign.
Get irish.
Just fucking go for it.
Go for it.
Just I'm tired.
Dude.
Is enough time.
It's still 2015.
Okay.
November of 2016 is the cupcakes and
cocksucker ted cruz.
Hillary's got the pants,
suits you get the apron,
get in,
and we're all taught.
A year ago,
caitlin was bruce and no one gives a
fuck about it,
right?
Right.
Right now he's caitlyn,
right?
And everybody cares.
Everybody loves her,
right?
Right,
right.
Cupcakes and cock sucking for president
ted cruz.
Ted.
Oh my god.
That's what's up.
He looks just he hollow black eyes.
He's just a guy just trying to fucking
stand down and make.
Just trying to pick himself up as
bootstraps and make the american dream
has just always weird.
It's always weird when someone goes,
they go that route.
AntI same sex marriage going against the
grain.
It's like I'm in a still prosecute
miracle.
There's no place for gays.
Look at that fucking quote.
This is.
There is no place for gays or atheists
in my America.
None.
Our constitution makes that clear.
He said that in fucking march 15 at
liberty university that has no place for
gays or ads.
That's so silly.
That's obviously a gay guy.
I hate to quote myself,
but there's two types of people that
hate gay marriage or people that are
really dumb or people that are secretly
worried that dicks are delicious.
I couldn't look at them.
That is of a john.
Don't stick it in my mouth because I'll
throw up.
Go ahead and I'll show it.
Don't put it in my.
But this is the world we live in.
abby martin.
Is that the empire now?
What does a guy like that fit in?
Where does a guy like that fit in the
empire is just like some guys
scrambling,
trying to get attention and run around
the outside of the castle.
What about me?
I can be keen on that guys.
So you have these.
He's not really.
He's just a side show,
you know?
I know some people just like rick perry
Of the nigger had rent.
What branch and what?
What is that ranch?
What are you talking to?
Rick perry's ranch.
Shut the fuck up.
His family.
Our family has a ranch called end.
John,
please tell me your kenny.
LIke refuse to take on the people and
when he was running for president,
people were like,
are you gonna?
Do like a rebranding effort about like
the ranch that your family owns?
And he was like,
it's all like historical.
Oh no,
it's.
I can't.
You're,
my mother knows that real.
It's real.
Come on.
Find that.
Oh my god,
it's true.
Oh my god.
He's got a ranch called nigger head.
Price yet?
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Perry's version of the events difference
in many respects.
Elections of seven people.
They painted the rock when they got the
offensive word saw the offensive word
and they painted it over.
Oh,
ever since.
Anytime I ever saw the rock,
it was painted over.
Oh my god.
My mother and father went to the lease
and painted the rock.
Went to the least.
What does that mean?
Went to the release and painted the
rock.
Neither 1983 or 1985.
Took them that long moves,
not until the eighties,
and we realized that it was a bad that
have really had to start respecting the
damn black people around Texas.
ThAt's just what we call folks.
Wait,
and didn't he also keep a dead fetus in
his fridge?
Oh my god.
Is that really the sign that you showed?
No.
That's fake,
right?
He kept a dead fetus in his fridge.
For what?
Just because she put them like,
it's good.
It's good.
You don't want to waste those cells.
You don't want to throw those in the
trash truck or used to sell that to the
black market.
It would be if it was aborted fetuses
that cured the gay q.
Imagine how ironic you needed an aborted
fetus.
Rick santorum's dead baby ritual.
What is that?
Fuck.
I don't want to say that.
Getting bummed out.
Anyway,
I got to end this thing in about five
minutes.
Oh shit.
REally?
Unfortunately.
I got a crazy day.
Oh no.
Wait.
Well,
anything else going on?
Uh,
just everyone check out the grand
staircase.
What's going on with your art?
You have beautiful art.
When we were in town doing some art.
Yeah,
I did an art show called cosmos itself
and I'm actually doing another one in
two days.
Everyone should check it out.
If they live in the la area called ethos
space,
it's going to be in downtown la.
Check it out.
Don't tons of freaky spot now,
isn't it?
It's fucking awesome,
man.
We're the fashion district and some
crazy warehouse.
I don't say where you live.
I'm moving in three days,
so it's fine.
Now you've got another ghost out.
There's a lot of freaky spots down
there.
YeAh,
like you gotta.
Make sure you don't go the wrong way
there.
Yeah.
Which is great.
It's like,
yeah,
I'm sure that you've seen.
You've traveled a lot of countries.
I've seen a lot of horrible poverty.
Went to hades,
sob bad things,
but then there's really nothing that
compares to skid row because it's this
crazy community living on the fucking
street just taking over downtown la,
like excess of huManity that's just
spilled out mentally ill drug.
I mean they're just like shooting up in
the street,
taking a shit.
It's fucking nuts.
Thousands of them.
Thousands,
and it's blocks and blocks and blocks.
It's just lIke society is just like
abandoned this portion of their people.
It's very surreal and really scary and
we live right by.
There is an interesting thing,
you know,
someone wants to look at them and go,
how do we capitalize on this market?
So many people's trust.
how do we,
how do we nail this homeless market?
I'm glad cans still going.
Strong body occupies just.
I was just making it work because you're
just right there.
You're like,
wow.
Oh,
like,
oh damn.
It's a fuckinG crazy scene.
I remember the first time I was there,
we were filling fear factory downtown
and we were real close to it and someone
brought it up and we drove by and how
you gotta be fucking kidding.
This is real.
It's real.
Super big and there's no one and like,
what do you do?
Most of them are just mentally ill and
drug addicts,
so it's like you don't.
What can you do other than provide
services like that.
It's very just.
And then one of the fucking tens.
It's so bizarre.
Has a giant american flag in it and
you're like,
I'm glad that you are still mirko all
about America.
Little fucking skid row living america's
fault that I'm out here.
My phone,
I'm the one to smoke the crack.
Uncle sam didn't put the correct pipe in
my mouth.
I didn't work hard enough.
Yeah.
Well the american dream,
there's a lot of mentally ill people
during the reagan administration,
they sort of changed the rules for what
made you're mentally ill and what the
distinctions were and that's when they
sort of opened up the doors and let all
these people on the street.
I remember it like really,
really clearly when I was a kid because
there was a big debate like,
oh,
like wait a minute.
You can't eat,
and there's a lot of people that are
like,
you can't fucking do with those.
You can't just change the
classification.
The classification for people that have
mental illness,
but they did and all throughout New York
and boston.
That was like all these new mentally ill
people wandering around the streets.
it was like a real clear moments there.
I just read the statistic that
homelessness has gone up like 25 percent
in the last four years,
just in la if people homes on freeway
overpass and jet and I remember like I
told you the five percent swear to god
and I remember I posted it and someone
was like,
dude,
just move out.
They can't afford la.
Just move out.
And I'm like,
I can't afford them.
Once you go homeless,
you don't have any money.
dude speaking really quickly before we
wrap it up,
I wanted to tell you I,
we sHould talk about Cuba next time
because I there and did a whole report
on
it,
but I'm zero homelessness.
That was the most iconic thing about
being in Cuba.
No trash,
no homelessness because everyone has
their basiC needs,
the shelter and there's rational system
and stuff,
but it was just interesting to see like
the low crime rate when people have like
basic shelter and healthcare,
a lot of problems still very interesting
because I.
It was very different than every other
latin american country.
I was just like,
holy shit.
There's no homeless people.
Beggars and.
No,
that's interesting.
Yeah,
it's not an ideal environment because
you're forced into certain jobs and they
kind of decide what you do on certain
jobs,
you know?
Nope,
that's bullshit.
What about for athletes when they do
that for athletes?
So that's what my friend who's an
economist actually when I came back from
Cuba,
she was like,
so how is it like everyone's assigned a
job?
And I was like,
no,
it's not like a brave new world where
we're babies are born in incubators and
trained to be like,
you're a doctor,
you're a florist,
your this is not like that at all.
And um,
you know,
there is a rational system and they do
get paid very little.
Um,
but it's just interesting because people
just have a completely different
mindset.
Like I remember I spoke to a bunch of
doctors and I was like,
why are you a doctor?
You're not getting paid anything.
Like why would I care about it?
They're like,
I'm helping my community and family.
It's just like completely.
It's just like a totally like a wall of
understanding.
I'm like,
I'm coming from the hub of capitalism
and I'm like,
I don't understand the incentive.
So it's really,
it was really,
really fascinating.
But I'd recommend everyone check out.
Um,
the Cuba series I did on breaking the
set if you want to learn more and I'm
checkout ethos space.
Abby martin.org
is my part that have lived there and
Cuba really hated it.
They hated the oppression.
They hated the way they were treated.
They escaped because they had more
opportunity in America.
You launched the athletes.
There's three laws that America has put
into place that coke's defectors.
So one of them is basically trying to
subvert cuba's whole medical
internationalism.
So Cuba has been forced into this like
because of the blockade,
the embargo,
they've been forced into like total
fucking self,
like you know what I mean,
like had like all organics and they have
like,
like maintain these old cars and they
like don't let anything break down and
kinda cool.
And so they've also developed instead of
invading countries and bombing the shit
out of people,
they've also developed an entire,
like a medical thing for their income.
So they basically lease out doctors
around the world,
even when you go back to the Haiti
earthquake,
they were the first country that sent
out the biggest contingent of doctors,
a bola biggest contingent of.
So they basically leased out like
doctors to get oil from Venezuela to
like get help.
Um,
it's interesting because people are
like,
oh,
well they're,
you know,
they're like creating doctors to like
just get oil and shit.
It's like,
well,
there,
they're doing what they can with the
resources that they have.
They're under a very crippling economic
embargo.
They have subversion programs going on
through usa id every year.
Despite the normalization process that's
going on.
The usa id is still spending $20,000,000
a year to subvert cuba's political
process.
So we've subverted the hip hop movement
that we've created a fake hiv program.
We've created a fake twitter called zoom
zoom that's tried to like get people
against castro.
But the most disturbing part is this
medical internationalism where you have
like 75,000
doctors working around the world on all
these fronts.
And the us has created a law that said
you can defect to the us and become a
doctor here and just leave your posts.
So it's like,
why are we trying to subvert like actual
medical missions and humanitarian
missions that cuba's doing?
Really the only reason is because we
want to subvert the socialist government
that survived after the cold war that we
still fucking can't accept.
And there's also the wet foot dry foot
policy that offers a cuban immigrants.
No other immigrant in the world has this
where you can just come here and just be
an american citizen if you're keeping.
Because no questions asked what foot
drive still?
Yep.
Wow.
That must suck for mexicans.
Like,
what the fuck,
man?
I'm like,
what is this bullshit like,
why shut down.
I did not know that.
That's fascinating.
It's really fascinating.
You should have a conversation with joey
diaz.
He'd be fucking screaming,
right?
He went to Cuba,
came over on a boat and you know,
a lot of people,
um,
look when you're a cuban and your,
your,
your honor ration system and you're
living in this country that's kind of
isolated and you're like watching
american movies and you're like,
why the fuck am I here?
Can be there,
you know,
and you're seeing mountains of cocaine
and the cases and you're like,
why?
But the problem is a lot of doctors
defect and they come over here and then
they're,
they're caught for years and years and
years they're,
they're licensed,
doesn't apply like they have to go
through all day.
Ended up being like a waitress in a
restaurant for a decade,
trying to become a practicing doctor.
But when I was over there,
not only they have free health care
obviously for everyone in the country,
but they also have an international
medical school that trains doctors.
Whoever wants to train all over the
world can go and just be a doctor for
free.
So I met like 20 americans who were
there and I was like,
why are you here getting your medical
license?
And they're like,
because I don't want to fucking be
$100,000
in debt in America,
and they're like,
I'm here to get my medical license so
then I can go train and be a doctor.
Wow.
Free.
So a lot of shit can be talked about how
things are run,
but it's a totally different society
when you have basic needs met and when
healthcare and like humans come first
out of necessity because of the blockade
because they had to create this.
Not necessarily of altruism,
but it's evolved in this such an insane.
Just dichotomy of how society has
functioned super interesting.
What's going to be fascinating now the
embargo has been lifted.
It's going to be lifted.
It's still not enough.
So now look,
travel restrictions.
Yeah.
So now they've looked at travel
restrictions and now raul has like
opened up some private enterprise and
stuff and that was a whole diplomatic
process within the country to where they
lifted some economic things.
So now private businesses can flourish
and so it's opening up because they've
realized that they can't obviously have
it like that forever.
Especially now that the travels lifted,
but it's gonna be really interesting to
see what happens,
especially now that the us still has
this aversion tactics going on,
these programs in place that encouraged
people to defect and then also get.
It's a perpetual
occupation of fucking Cuba that raul has
said time and again,
give us guantanamo bay.
You leased it under false pretenses.
We really want it back and the us as
it's off the table.
So that's the way the empire works back
basis.
So how has that.
We liked least it 19.
Oh three.
We leased the guantanamo bay naval base
was just a giant swath of land for
housing,
but it's connected to Cuba.
It's on Cuba in Cuba.
So we lease it.
Then what's battista was an alum,
our boy,
but tessa was like a corporate fucking
lord,
you know.
And so we had all these private
enterprises in Cuba and,
and the socialist revolution happened
and then the lease agreement said this
has to be agreed by both parties to
continue or I'm sorry to dissolve.
And then when the cuban revolution
happened,
Cuba was like,
give us back guantanamo and the us was
like,
you know,
we don't agree to that,
so we're just gonna keep it.
And they never accepted a diamond,
never cashed a dime for the rent lease
after the 1956 or whatever the,
um,
the revenue.
So yeah,
it was,
that's really disturbing to me because
I'm like,
dude,
just fucking go down to a bay.
Like you can pretend that were normal
with coupa,
but it's never gonna be normal unless
you give them some respect and if you're
so scared of socialism and if you are so
sure that socialism is a failure,
then let them fucking fail on their own.
Lift the block caden,
let Cuba just function and let's see
what happens.
But right now,
um,
it's been so crippled in so many ways
that it's impossible to really know what
the country would be like without us
interference.
Well,
it's very bizarre that we're allowed to
trade with all sorts of different
countries that are accused of all sorts
of different heinous crimes against
humanity.
But we can't with Cuba.
I mean,
just thinking about all the different
countries that we're allowed to trade
with.
It's fun to go to the Congo right now,
hang out with you,
do whatever the fuck you want.
You know,
Saudi Arabia,
we go back and forth with them all the
time.
Chicks just got the right to vote.
You hear that like weeks,
like it was on.
It was in the news yesterday.
Oh my god.
If my twitter.
Jimmy.
Yeah,
it was Saudi Arabia.
Women in Saudi Arabia are going to get
the right to vote now.
Hallelujah.
Look,
it's 2015 I guess.
Take off your burqas.
Nope.
Nope,
no,
I'll do that.
We have at liberty than yet.
No,
well,
I live in Iran.
They were just fucking tons of makeup.
They look hot as fuck and I just wear
skin tight clothes because you're not
allowed to show shit,
but they were like yoga pants,
like a total work around,
but they have to have that thing on
their head.
Woman are allowed to vote in Saudi
Arabia for the first time in history.
That's August 24th,
2015.
Bam.
15th,
15 for the first time in the country's
history,
women's,
Saudi Arabia.
I've been given the right to vote and
stand as political candidates in the
upcoming elections.
Wow.
But it's just amazing,
but just don't,
don't drive.
Don't your ankles have your.
I guess the man needs to escort them to
the voting booths because they still
can't do anything without a male
permission.
Of course.
It can't even drive.
They can vote and they can't drive.
You have the king,
the former king.
I'm sorry.
Praise be with him.
Fucking peace be upon him.
He used to be upon abdula,
but no,
his daughters are like trapped in a
dungeon.
Like being starved.
What?
Yeah,
they're like living in underground in
some bunker that like they're trapped.
They did an interview with someone and
saying,
help us.
We're.
We like disobeyed our father and we're
being punished for.
Yeah,
it's super crazy.
You look it up.
Grand staircase to go to the grand
staircase.
Every time I talked to abby martin,
she gets more depressing.
Things to look up listening.
Always.
Awesome.
Talk to me anytime you want.
Anytime.
Anytime my friend.
All right,
that's it for today.
You fucks the shit out yet and we'll see
you soon.
Bye.